>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Stacy: Now what I'm going
to do is turn it over to Kurt
for our third session.
Thank you again.
>> Kurt Helfrich: Thank
you very much, Stacy.
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome back, and I do hope
that you all had an enjoyable
lunchbreak with opportunities
to see old colleagues
and get to know new ones.
My name is Kurt Helfrich
and I'm an Archivist
in the National Gallery of
Art's Gallery Archives here
in Washington, D.C. It is a real
pleasure and honor to be able
to moderate this session
on access use cases.
Before I introduce today's
speakers I hope you won't mind a
slight digression.
Being here today I am
reminded of a comment made
by my British colleague,
Charles Hind, at a conference
on digital design records I
was involved with that was held
at the Royal Institute
of British Architects
in London in 2013.
At the end of the conference
Charles challenged us to,
in quotes, show me the uses
by external researchers
for these digital files
and I will really begin
to understand their
value, end quote.
Today's speakers
are doing just that.
Through their presentations
they are helping us
to understand how researchers
are and will be making use
of not just digital
files, but datasets.
They are also examining
the context
in which these files are
created as a means for us
to further understand their
potential research value.
And now I'd like to briefly
introduce today's four speakers.
Please note that more extensive
biographies of them can be found
on the Symposium website.
So our first presenter
today is Andrew Witt
and Andrew is Assistant
Professor in the Practice
of Architecture at
the Graduate School
of Design, Harvard University.
Our second presenter
will be Euan Cochrane,
who is the Digital
Preservation Manager
at Yale University's Library.
Our third presenter
is Matthew Allen,
who is a Doctoral Candidate
at Harvard University's Graduate
School of Design and teaches
at the University of Toronto's
John H. Daniel's Faculty
of Architecture,
Landscape and Design.
Our final and fourth
speaker is Dennis Shelden,
who is Associate
Professor and Director
of the Digital Building
Laboratory
at the Georgia Tech School
of Architecture in Atlanta.
We are keeping our speakers
to a tight 15-minute schedule
to allow time following their
presentations for questions
from the audience, so
I'm afraid we're going
to be a bit draconian.
With that, though, I would
like to ask Andrew Witt to come
up to the podium and
begin his presentation.
Thank you very much.
>> Andrew Witt: So we heard
a lot about structured data
in the first half a day.
I'm going to go in exactly the
opposite direction and talk
about a lot of unstructured
data and ways to deal with that,
or semi-structured data
I guess I would say.
So the expanded intellectual and
technical scope of architecture
in the 20th and 21st Centuries
has drawn architects the use
of automation to organize and
scale information and work.
Automation includes both
commercial authoring software
and the customized
scripts and softwares
that designers, themselves,
create.
These methods encapsulate or
black box domain knowledge
to be applied automatically.
And I showed this
image just to mention
like in a previous life
Dennis and I worked together
at Deerey Technologies
and I curated this sort
of like portion of this massive
retrospective of the provenance
of Frank Deerey's use of
technology, and so a lot
of my perspective is
shaped by like digging
through those archives
and trying
to reassemble what actually
went on when those things were,
when those buildings
were being put together.
So scripting has significantly
impacted how design is developed
and, thus, how historians must
understand digital documents.
So here I'm going to propose
three implications of that.
First, source code as
a historical document.
Second, digital forensics,
and I realized actually
after the first session that
I'm using this term forensics
in a slightly different way
than the sort of technical term
of art sense, but
we'll get into that.
And, third, AI archival agents.
Ultimately the possibility is
that historians, themselves,
might script their own tools
to understand these documents
and at the frontiers of this
possibility are the applications
of things like sentiment
analysis, machine vision,
artificial intelligence to crawl
archives, yes, to crawl archives
and sort of make sense
of them at a large scale.
So this is a video
of a textual analysis
of important theoretical text
from the '60s called
the pattern language.
It applies sentiment
analysis ideas
to theoretical architectural
text and then compares them
to understand who is being
sort of the most polemic,
the most sort of like unbiased,
and the most sort of hyperbolic.
So computational processes
in design have given rise
to new kinds of collateral
documents,
and one potentially very
rich new archive, obviously,
these scripts and
code bases themselves
for the applications
developed specifically
for design projects.
The language in which code
is written, the organization
of its components, the subject
domains of the external modules
that it draws on, all of these
reveal certain proclivities
in the way that designers choose
to organize technical knowledge.
And it suggests how
designers, themselves,
might feel about how
architectural practice might
evolve in the future.
So each of them are sort of
like putting a stake in the sand
about how they think the
discipline should evolve.
So let's contrast two projects
that are actually drawn
from the CCA's digital
archive --
Mark Goldfarb's [assumed
spelling] hypo surface
and Chuck Hoberman's iris dome.
So we'll begin with
the iris dome.
So both of these projects are
large geometrically complex
kinematic installations
with very sophisticated
mechanical systems.
Both are composed of hundreds
of custom moving parts
and they both relied
on extensive scripted automation
directed by the designer.
But the distinction
between the use of scripting
and automation is I
think very revealing,
so we'll begin with Hoberman.
So Hoberman's archive preserves
about 74 distinct scripts
developed in the lisp language
of AutoCAD, so any
of you who have been
around for a little while
that probably takes you back.
These scripts were
used to layout
and draw the mechanical
components
of his complex assemblies
and, thus,
were reused on multiple
projects.
It became a sort of
repository for knowledge reuse.
It became a way to automate
and parametrically adapt
certain aspects of the design.
And on the dome project
Hoberman had
about 12 different specific
scripts for that project
and about 52 drawing files.
So as a general rule maybe like
20% of the design intelligence
of the project was
embedded in the source code.
So Hoberman developed
these tools as pragmatic,
on a pragmatic and
on demand basis
to address very specific
problems, so it's really obvious
when you're reading
through these
that he wrote them himself,
he didn't really
document them extensively,
if you know anything
about source code there were
very, very few comments.
And the way in which they're
written is kind of like it's raw
in a way, but it's
also very adaptable.
They're written in a code style
which suggests a very
specific single author and user
and very sort of like targeted
and tactical applications.
So Mark Goldfarb's approach
to hypo surface was
quite different.
It was a single and
unique project,
a significant monumental
project,
but a single project nonetheless
and there was no
knowledge with use per se.
Instead there was
a need through code
to manage a complex
collaboration structure.
So the project demanded
support from a range
of unusual consultants,
people like mathematicians,
megatronics experts, pneumatics
engineers, rubber researchers.
So architects are no
strangers to collaboration,
but these particular domains
were quite I would say foreign
to typical architecture
practice.
So the single software
application became one
of the templates for managing
that collaborative knowledge.
So, yes, there wasn't
knowledge use per se,
and so there was a need
to manage these domains.
So the software components
were developed
by Goldfarb's team members,
primarily Zaviae Rubitai
[assumed spelling],
who is sort of like
listed in this organogram.
And instead of a flat list of
the spoke scripts as you have
in Hoberman's case the hypo
service team hierarchically
combined componentized libraries
into more extensive packages
and a single coordinated
software.
So you have a more
hierarchical organization,
which essentially mirrors
the project team structure.
So mathematical,
mechanical, electrical control
and design parameters all
coexisted in the software.
It wasn't intended actually
to automate the design
of the hypo surface,
as in Hoberman's case,
but instead to automate
its control
and in particular the motion
of the hundreds of
linear actuators.
So here in this exploded
assay you can see
where those linear
actuators fall.
And I think it's kind
of interesting is you
have the layers of sort
of like electrical control,
sort of like this very
specific this spoke rubber,
the actuators themselves,
and the architecture kind
of like mirrors in a
certain way the script
organization actually.
Yes, so Hoberman and Golfarb's
approaches illustrate two
architype of different
approaches to code.
The artisan computational
designer, maybe in the case
of Hoberman, on the one hand
and the organization
builder on the other.
One effectively synthesizes
knowledge,
synthesizes that knowledge him
or herself, so Hoberman was sort
of like a sculptor, an
architect and an engineer.
The other is a means, the
other uses code as a means
of knowledge synthesis.
So both are kind of
forerunners in a certain way
of approaches that we see today.
Now computers are not
only geometry producers,
but they're also
recorders, obviously.
So a digitally conceived
drawing is, in fact,
just an automatic
log of transactions.
And the operations recorded
therein are sometimes atomically
stamped with things
like time, location,
and authorship information.
The automatic nature of digital
recording can actually be a tool
for very interesting forensic
reconstruction processes.
So a curious quality of these
particular kinds of sequences
of operation is that they record
chronologically not only human
authorship, but also
the sequence
of certain algorithmic
processes.
So I should mention
there's some great work here
from Jona Rhys Meyers and
Renbe [assumed spelling],
who were involved
with this project.
So different software
generates the same dome
in different ways
leading to distinct
and characteristic
operational footprints.
For example, this diagram
compares a different programs
log operationally sequences
in slightly different ways.
>> Five minutes, so.
>> Andrew Witt: Really, okay.
My stopwatch says
differently, but maybe.
Thanks to the journaled
and sequential nature
of digital design files we
can reconstruct the chronology
of their creation.
So with certain formats, I mean
it's very format particular,
but this allows us to see step
by step how a designer
modeled the particular form.
It can even allow us to see
gaps, erasures and hesitations.
So here we see the timeline
of a particular Revit file
and the sort of like
chronological deconstruction
of that file.
So at the far right you see a
sort of like linear sequence
of how the designer
actually modeled that file.
So we can visualize
these sequences
as three dimensional exploitive
econometrics revealing a kind
of digital column SaaS
and literally see the
design process unfold.
So this is a matrix of a series
of these kind of exploited axos,
and it's very, you know, it's
revealing in certain cases
because you begin to understand,
okay, what are the problems
that the architect sort of
like really labored over,
what are the problems which
were really sort of like done
as a matter of course,
and we can begin
to interpret priorities in
these sort of expanded drawings.
So, yes, it's possible to track,
journal and visualize authorship
in real time, just as -- yes,
so it's possible to do this
in real-time, as well.
So just as our eyes track
irregular cicada patterns,
designers in the sort of
irregular way also rotate,
flip and work with their models.
I'm not sure how this line
drawing is coming through,
but essentially this is
a process of modeling
which has tracked the motions
of the designer, themselves.
So you can see how the
designer manipulates the models.
You can begin to sort of create
this kind of like cyclometrics
of design purely
from these logs.
And here's another
example of that.
So briefly I want to
mention maybe a new frontier,
which is kind of alluded
to in the first session.
Advances in techniques from data
science and AI allow us to work
with these logs and
digital files in new ways.
So often associated
with big data trends
and machine learning
they're highly relevant
for less structured
sets of data.
So images that we
might have from as sort
of like project collateral, sort
of the visual representation
of models as opposed to
their data representation,
we can begin to scan these
and use machine vision
to classify them in
historically interesting ways.
So I'll mention an example,
not directly archival
but with archival implications,
here we see a machine
vision algorithm --
or, sorry, this is an example
of a façade which the way
that the human would see
it on the left and the way
that the machine would
see it on the right,
and from this network
you can sort
of like prioritize certain kinds
of operations which extract sort
of invariance about
what this façade means
and you can use this for very
broad classifications of forms.
So this example is not
directly archivable,
but it has archivable
implications.
This is a machine
vision algorithm,
crawling a New York City
plan and classifying
by common plan outline of
thousands of buildings.
And so this is the -- you'll
see over time it builds actually
like this phylogenetic
tree of form,
just from the morphological
characteristics.
And what's interesting about
this is that imagine you were
to take a museum
archive of visual objects
or building documents or
façade elements or 3D models
and ask questions about
how do these, what are all
of the possible precedents
for this one object?
This is a way to actually do
that by scaling up machine,
scaling up human intuition into
a sort of machine platform.
And so this is sort of a zoomed
out view of 100,000 buildings
in central Berlin, so here
you see those buildings sort
of like clustered by
similarity, and as you move back
out you begin to see these
kind of like continents of form
that emerge from
that classification.
So the software draws new
charts of the past that allow us
to make sense of what we build
holistically and to map all
of architecture as it were.
We can algorithmically
map our cultural
heritage comprehensively.
So these are just a couple of
the ways in which new archives,
these new archives, these
files considered almost
as logs allow us new ways
of addressing questions
about the design process.
So how do designers organize
and encapsulate knowledge,
how do different
designers draw differently,
how do designers proceed
in the design process,
and how does the whole catalog
of built form relate
holistically.
So these examples reveal new
possibilities for the use
of programmatic information
generated by both the designer
and the historian to
uncover the heuristic
and epistemic methods of design.
So I think I got it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Euan Cochrane: I'm going to
talk about emulation for access.
I was asked to talk about
a particular use case.
I can talk about this more
generally, but I'm going to go
through a particular use case.
This is it, I can't remember
exactly when this was,
but some months ago we had
a small architecture design
archivist meeting
and symposium at Yale
and the Architecture School.
And at the time the Academy for
Architecture and the head of,
in collaboration with,
they had an exhibit
in the Architecture School about
archaeology of the digital.
And I worked with Tim Walsh up
at CCA and Susie in the archives
at Yale to put together
this workstation
in which the user
can just click into.
And they gave a screen, an HTML
screen like this with a list
of environments that
they can click on.
Now when they click on those
it loads an emulated version
of the original environment,
the original computer associated
with those designer codes
and they can interact
with them using the
original software.
And I was going to put
some screenshots in here,
expecting none of this to
work, but I think it is kind
of working so I will try and
show you what that looks like.
The example I just showed
in that photo was all
running on a local computer.
It's what we call the reading
room or exhibit implementation
of this software that we're
using, but it also runs
in a web browser,
that's the standard way
to access this emulation
framework.
And I'll talk more about it, but
just to show you what it's like.
For the end user whenever
they want to interact
with something they get a link
and they click on the link
and it loads the environment
automatically in the background.
So this is Windows
'98, as you'll see.
[ Music ]
Clicked the wrong button there.
Try that again.
Yes, so I'm loading it again,
but Windows, as you saw,
it's just the click of
a button, it loads up.
And what the user gets presented
with in this case is
a folder of files.
[music] Right, so this
example is actually
from Balmori Associates.
We had someone from
there talk this morning.
It's in the archives at Yale.
And if I open this
now it'll open
in AutoCAD release 14 I think.
Right, and I can click that
and you see the diagram.
And you can just interact
with it like you would
if using the original software,
so in a minute we'll
have you -- and it works.
Let's see if I have this on
here while I'm here, so go ahead
and see if the clip runs.
[laughter] There it goes.
[applause] Right, so
I'll start this one.
Go back to the slides
and start talking
about this technology briefly.
So emulation is a service is
what's being used to power all
of this, both the online version
you just saw and the one we had
on the device in the room, the
reading room implementation.
It provides remote access to
preconfigured virtual computers
that can be accessed
with one click.
It can be done by a web browser
or in a reading room
environment.
It just requires a web browser,
any modern web browser
can access this.
And one of the best things
about it is it abstracts
away all the issues
with configuring emulators from
the end users and even the staff
and archives and
libraries and so
on because they can be
preconfigured by experts
and the user then just needs
to add the content to them
or the staff maybe can just add
the content, click the button
and it loads in the
browser for them.
You can also choose to configure
these environments so that
when an end user
does something inside
of it it is either saved or not.
And most cases, in most cases
we just say let them save it,
they can do anything,
they can delete things,
they eat it, we don't care.
Because when the next user goes
to it it'll be exactly
the same as it was before.
Oh, talk a little more about how
this configuration happens next,
but another key attribute
of this is
that you can restrict
interactivity.
So you can make it so that
users can't print anything
from within the environment.
You can make it so that they
can't download or copy anything
out of the environment.
The worst a user could do
would be to take a screenshot,
and if you restrict
this to a reading room
that even becomes less relevant.
And all the emulations
run remotely
and the users are actually
accessing it via the web browser
as kind of a remote
desktop tool.
So the process I went through
to configure that workstation
for the reading room was
somewhat complicated,
and we're doing a lot of work
to automate a lot of this away
so that other users
that want to use this
in the future won't have
to go through this process,
but I'll walk you
through it briefly.
So what we do is we
create a basic environment
and then we add layers
on top of that.
We are actually going a step
further than we might need to.
We're buying original
hardware or getting donations
and then we're making an
image of the hard drives
and putting those directly into
the emulation framework so that
if someone in the future
really wanted to validate
that the emulation was accurate
they could come and try it
out on the original
hardware for as long
as that hardware is
going to be around.
So then we load those into
our emulation framework,
you can see a list here,
and then we just start getting
software to go into those.
I mentioned that software,
here's a slightly
more relevant example
that I never actually
managed to get working
because of a hardware dongle,
and we put that software
in here.
And then we configured that
using the online interface,
just it gets attached as a CD or
whatever to the base environment
and you just install
the software
like you normally would.
And then you can click
a button, save it,
and it saves a new environment
with that software installed.
And the way it does that by the
way is it creates a derivative
of the original environment,
so it only saves the difference
between that first
master environment
and whatever you've added to it.
So from a preservation speak
if you don't have the cost
of replicating all that data
of the base environment
every time you make a change
to create a derivative.
Now that process doesn't always
work for this particular setup.
I actually ended up having to
install the software in one case
on the original computer and
continually image the drive
as I added more content.
The reason being
that the emulator
for this particular operating
system didn't allow us
to change disks while it was
running and to install something
that was 10 disks I had to do
it on the original computer
and then image that computer.
So it's not always
that straightforward,
but we're making progress.
And to fix this particular
problem all that actually needs
to happen is some
developer needs to add
that feature to that emulator.
We just haven't got there yet.
Here's some photographs I took.
All right, now for the reading
room setup what we had was just
a little Intel mix unit of
computing, Nook computer,
what you see in the red box
there, which I first tested
with some old hardware
plugged into it.
And then I got a little
software running on it
and I was using more modern
hardware to connect to it.
And then for the actual
exhibit I did what looked
like older hardware,
but actually in reality
that little computer is
back there somewhere.
So this was just that computer
on the left there is just
completely doing nothing.
[laughter] So you see
it in the space there,
and there is a little
computer sitting back there
that people don't see,
so that's just a prop
for that other computer.
All right, so there are a
lot of challenges with this.
Here's some of them.
Actually I'll show you
a few more in a demo,
which might be more relevant.
Twelve, yes.
Here is -- one second.
This mouse has a
back button on it
that I keep accidently hitting.
Why don't we try this one.
This was an absolute
pain to configure.
It's AutoCAD release 12 for
Microsoft DOS and just to get it
to install was crazy,
far too difficult,
but now that it's installed I
can add any content to this.
I can share that environment
with others depending
on all the intellectual
property challenges,
and then they can add
the content and use this
to study now that
it's configured.
So in here another
thing we see is that --
I'm not very good with
the mouse on this.
Is it working still?
No, I'll just restart that.
What you'll see is that when
you go to open a file in here,
firstly, you need to know
that there's a menu up there
and most end users these
days have no clue how
to use Microsoft DOS software
and would you have known
to move the mouse up to
the top quadrant to see
that there's a menu so you
can go and open the file?
Would you know the command
to open a file in MS DOS?
That's a challenge, it was
certainly a challenge for me,
and I just happened
to find this.
[laughter] So now
I can go through
and you'll see the next issue.
I go into the folder that
has the files and open one.
You can't find this file,
which is I believe a font file.
So it turns out after having
a look around in here,
AutoCAD actually
comes with some fonts
so you can just replace
the one that it's looking
for with an AutoCAD one.
But this is too difficult,
right?
We can definitely
improve on this.
Either way eventually you
get in here and, whoops.
I'll put a Gothic font in,
and there you go,
there's the D file.
But those kind of issues, the
fact that the object didn't come
with fonts it reflects
the kind of things
that were discussed this morning
about modern design environments
where you have multiple
dependencies
and if you don't have them all
you may not get the same thing
that you were expecting
originally.
This has been happening
for a very long time,
including in Microsoft DOS.
Let's see if I can show
you one more thing.
This is slightly less relevant,
but I'm going to show you
because I tweeted
about it this morning
and it might be of
some interest.
We have been going through
our general collections
in the library and imaging all
of our CDs on floppy disks,
which we have far too many,
thousands, and we're going
to start providing
access to them,
but our emulation is a service.
This is the configuration
interface you're seeing here.
What we're trying to do is
make this extremely simple
for configuration and then
we're just going to have a link
in the catalog for each of them,
and this interface now is able
to suggest which environments
that CD is likely to run on.
And then configuring staff
then can just test one of them,
and actually what it does is it
scans all the files on the disk.
You can see the file formats
down on the list here.
And it says these file
formats probably run
on these environments, you
might want to try one of those.
But this one in particular,
the only reason I'm putting it
up here is because it happens
to have a few design files on it
which I thought were
kind of interesting.
So as a configurem user this
might be the process we would
use [music] for staff to try
to get an environment set-up
to provide access to
some end user to some
of your architectural records.
You would attach them
through the interface
or you could upload
them or what have you.
And what we should
see is that they end
up in a CD ROM drive on here.
I could browse that, but I'm
just going to double click
and open and in this
case it just runs.
And what I would do now if I was
configuring this is I would put
a link into the start menu,
into the startup area so that
when the computer starts mix
time it will automatically load
to the screen, and then all
I do is hit create object
environment, put in some
metadata and it'll get saved
and you'll get a link back
that you can then provide
to any users, put in your
catalog and what have you,
and that's as easy as it is,
it's fairly straightforward.
Let's see if there's anything
we need to look at on here.
And right now we have all
sorts of operating systems
and environments available
preconfigured, but we're going
to be adding more and more.
So we'll just go
back to the slides.
So, as I've mentioned and shown
a few up there, there are a lot
of challenges getting
to the point we did
with just the exhibit
environment.
We had to get all the
hardware and the software,
configure all the
emulators, configure
and install the software on
those emulator environments.
We had to deal with DRM,
including just license key
but also in the case of Form Z I
wasn't able to get that working
because I had a hardware dongle
and I couldn't emulate
that at the time.
Intellectual property is
something that's another whole
topic, which I'm sure Brendan
and Peter could answer questions
about if you have any.
And then there are the issues
of the end user being able
to use the software,
which I showed you before
with the DOS example where it's
not intuitive anymore especially
to the younger folks who have
grown up with touchscreens,
for example, or mobile
devices, which we are going
to emulate a little bit of.
We can do early Android on
here which is quite nice.
And then there are, I mean
authenticity, so I don't know
if I loaded the AutoCAD 2002
environment, but it comes
up with a whole lot of pop-ups.
And you had a question
should I configure it
so that they automatically come
up and the user sees what it was
like or should I configure it so
they don't come up so it's not
as annoying if you just
want to get to the content?
And then you need to do things
like export the environments
if you want to use
them in a reading room.
We're making that easier
so you can configure one
in the web environment,
export it so you can
put it on your stick.
By the way, this is all
that that reading room
environment thing runs off of.
I can plug this into my
laptop and run it off of that.
If I want to export one of those
environments to go on here,
though, we're making it a
little bit easier by making it,
you can just click a
button in the interface.
And then configuring
that exhibit hardware wasn't
entirely straightforward,
we had to get the right
dongles to get it up like
in the old hardware and so on.
All right, one minute.
So we're aiming to
make this really,
really easy for everybody.
I'm starting some work
soon in collaboration
with the Software
Preservation Network,
which if you have questions
about I'm sure Jessica
would be happy to answer.
To basically make it so
that there are a whole set
of preconfigured emulatable
computers available to anyone
that wants to participate
in this network of emulation
for service notes that we're
planning on putting together.
And so that you can just
say I've got this file,
give me the right
software to render it,
give me the original software,
and you'll get that back
in the web browser in
that original software.
Amongst other things,
there's a whole number
of various things we're going to
be doing with this general idea.
One of the things we would
love to be able to do
in the future is guide the
user through using the software
by adding layers on top of
the emulator environments
to say click here to do this,
you know, scroll here and so on.
And it's a pretty
straightforward thing
to do technologically,
we just need to get there
and that's going to take
a little bit longer.
And I mentioned here figures
for software, there's a project
that Brendan and Peter are doing
at the University of Virginia,
which is trying to establish our
rights to do this kind of thing
from an intellectual
property perspective.
I think we're moving on to the
next person, but I'd be happy
to answer questions later.
That is my hometown of New
Plymouth in New Zealand
and the new extension
to the art gallery,
this missile looking
building in the background,
which I think looks amazing.
[laughter] Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Matthew Allen: So what
I thought I could bring
to this particular panel
is a discussion of some
of the more normal ways
that a architectural historian
might use the digital archive.
[laughter] So the
projects I'll talk
about aren't using cutting edge
methods and they weren't carried
out with a lot of resources.
I wanted to highlight that
the typical conditions
under which an architectural --
>> There will be a rebuttal.
[laughter]
>> Matthew Allen: Especially
I'm thinking in particular
of historians approaching
a topic
that they aren't even sure
they want to commit to sort
of working on and what
they maybe might look
for in an archive.
So I'll discuss three
projects that have led so far
to three small exhibitions.
The starting point for the first
project was Greg Lynn's [assumed
spelling] observation about how
software is sometimes visible
in images of architectural
design.
In this case different
software allows users
to create different
types of lines or curves.
My question was given a bunch
of images of design projects
from a certain period
can we infer
which software was
used to make them?
Beyond this can we start
to analyze the feedback
between software and ways of
thinking about architecture?
From the time I spent in
the Exhibition Department
at the Harvard Graduate
School of Design I knew
that they had a set of student
projects that they collected
at the end of every semester.
Because these were just quick
student projects the images were
not very polished.
The evidence of the software
hadn't been scrubbed away,
so to speak.
This collection was not
really archived, per se.
The computing services team
had done some work putting the
collection in order,
but what I had to work
with was essentially a
pile of about 28,000 JPEGs
from about 5,000 projects and
an Excel file with all sorts
of different metadata.
So knowing that the files were
there I suggested an exhibition
to the school and
they graciously agreed
to give me a wall
in the library.
I also proposed linking the
show to research I was doing
on older software, so the
show became a dual exhibition
on software in the '60s and '70s
and software in the recent past.
Finally, part of the project was
to more properly archive the
student work so the idea was
to sort of usher the
work into the library,
both symbolically
and physically.
Because I had a hard drive
with all the files access was
not particularly difficult.
I made a copy of the files,
renamed them and looked
at them all with a few
different image viewers.
I tagged them, sorted
them, rearranged them based
on visual conventions that I
thought that I was interested in
and how I might be able
to use them in the show.
Part of the show was a
wash of all of the images,
so I wrote a script to shrink
them and combine them together
and lay them out in a series
of PDF files for printing.
Another section had the
names of all the students --
oh, here's a -- so
this is the wall.
Another section had the names
of all the students involved
so I copied and pasted from
Excel to InDesign for that.
[laughter] Finally, there was a
slide show that pulled out some
of the images and correlated
them with little bits of text
that sort of analyzed the
visual conventions involved,
so this slide show was
playing in the library.
This is what the exhibition
looked like in the end.
There was also a little
wall with screenshots
of current projects that
I solicited from students
at the school, sort
of a live feed
of what was happening
upstairs in the school.
I'll also note that my ambition
has been to put this research
into a sort of field guide
of the visual conventions
of architectural software
during this period,
so I was somewhat
rigorous about sort
of what I was looking
for in these files.
All right, one lesson
from this project begins
with the observation
that it only worked
because I had unusually
direct access to the files.
I could flip through thousands
of JPEG files, sort
them, tag them.
It's hard to imagine doing this
without direct access like that.
This was similar to digging
through physical
archives in some ways.
In both cases we're
confronted with a pile of stuff
which we can pull things
out from and put it back
as we want very quickly with
digital files creating this sort
of hands-on feeling
of manipulation is
essential I think.
I'd like to imagine that there's
no good reason it can't be made
possible to check-out
an entire archive
on an external hard
drive, for example.
My point here is that
historians are usually operating
under a severe time crunch,
especially when deciding whether
to work on a project or not,
and if it appears difficult
to get ahold of the files
they may choose not to take
on the project at all, right?
Okay, the second project
I'll talk about begins also
with a heap of files, but it
was a more heterogeneous heap.
The occasion for this
research was that an architect,
Preston Scott Cohen,
was given an opportunity
to do an exhibition of
a major project of his,
the Tel Aviv Museum of Art.
I was asked to help reconstruct
part of the design process
and I did some of
the preliminary work
and it was installed at Harvard.
Reconstructing the
design process would seem
to be relatively
straightforward.
The project was designed by a
small number of people and most
of them were still around.
It was an entirely
digital project.
A range of models and drawings
from the very beginning
of the project coexisted in
the firm's project archive,
so this is sort of a
picture of what you would see
at the opened -- yes, that
folder on their server.
And it existed in more or
less the same structure
as when it was being worked on,
so the organization was ad hoc,
let's say, but it
was easy to access.
I just had to go to the
office, plug into the server,
make a copy, and I could
use it as I wanted.
The problem, of course,
was that it was not
at all clear what were the
most important documents.
I could gather all the AutoCAD
or Rhino files into one place,
but it was difficult to know
which one contained the
important design decisions.
Because my research was destined
for an exhibition the architect
had some incentive to help,
of course, so I sat down
with him and went through all
of the files comparing
differences and trying to figure
out how sort of what changed
between the versions and why.
So the process involved
a lot of comparison
of different types of files.
We also in the process
made a bunch of diagrams.
In fact, it was through this
process of drawing diagrams
that a lot of the important
points came out and sort
of jogged their memory.
One of the coolest things
we found was this little
geometrical sketch, off to
the side, of one of the files,
which was later sort of moved
into the middle of the building
and became the sort of focal
point of the whole project
as you can see on the left.
All right, so it's clear
that insider knowledge
was key to the exhibition.
Without the architect
to carefully think
through the design process,
pulling out important moments
from the files would have been
a much more difficult task.
One useful archival
practice then,
and this was mentioned earlier
and especially for small firms,
would be to ask designers
to spend some time
after a project is over simply
copying and pasting sort
of some key files to a separate
folder that could serve as sort
of reference points later
on if you wanted to sort
of reconstruct the
design process.
All right, going through these
files I found a collection
of documents, I found that
a collection of documents
in their original order
provided some valuable clues
for the historian.
A folder structure
can tell you a lot.
File adjacencies are sometimes
meaningful to make sense
of a workflow, having
access to files
in their original structure
is sometimes crucial.
Things like scripts or reference
images, next to original models
or drawings, you know, can
make all the difference
in interpreting it.
In contemporary modeling
practices the best way to ensure
that a model would even
open correctly would be
to have a sort of snapshot of
the whole computer it seems like
and actually absent that
it's hard to guarantee
that some things would
even work at all, right?
I think ultimately that the
way to think about design needs
to change drastically as we
think about digital archives.
Sometimes I personally
lapse into imagining
that design is something an
architect does with pencil
and paper, and then I go to
look for sketches and drawings
for evidence of design
decisions.
But it's clear that with digital
design an architect is usually
looking over someone else's
shoulder as they're zooming in
and out, turning layers on
and off, and rotating things
to get just the right view.
The important thing is not
only to look at the right file,
but to have the right
viewpoint within the file,
the right combination
of layers and so on.
So digital files have a much
greater depth and complexity
than drawings on paper,
I mean we all know this.
But luckily historians can
approach archives in new ways.
We don't have to be
respectful of digital files
in the same way we are
careful about drawings.
We can make a copy of everything
and move things around,
cut out pieces, save as
new files, delete things,
create our own folder
structure and so on.
The more this can be
enabled I think the better.
All right, so the third project
that I'll just very briefly
discuss builds on the second.
As an architecture student I
came to appreciate the impact
of software limitations
and bugs on design.
If you know that a
program will crash
after you have let's say
10,000 of something you'll try
to design with only 9,000
of them, and then once
that bug is fixed
you'll go crazy and make
like 100,000 of them, right?
I know that 10 years ago
students were eagerly installing
beta versions of software
as soon as it came
out to use the latest features.
So this final project was an
exploration of the relationship
between the evolution of
software and the evolution
of architectural culture
and ultimately the evolution
of architecture,
itself, let's say.
I didn't begin with a
traditional archive,
but three different
sources of information.
The first was the change
log of Rhinoceros 3D,
a popular digital
modeling package.
I knew the change log
was available in pieces,
but I wasn't able to get it
directly from McNeel so I ended
up pulling it piece by piece
from archive.org actually.
The second source was text
and images from forums
that showed bugs that
architects encountered in Rhino.
And for the third I put a call
out to friends and students
for anecdotes about what they
thought was the most important
command in Rhino.
So the idea of the show
was to fill-up a wall
with the change logging and
to correlate the anecdotes
and the images with it.
So this is sort of
what it looked like.
So again it was to, so at
certain points you could see
in the change log that a new
command would be added to Rhino
and then there would be
anecdotes about like how
that particular command related
to architectural design, right?
So it made a good
conversation piece definitely.
Let's see, where are we -- and
it may have gotten some people
to think about the
link between the sort
of behind the scenes
practices of software design
and our own design work.
I wanted to show this project
here to emphasize the relevance
of all this seemingly peripheral
stuff to architectural projects.
If as a historian you're not
focusing on finished buildings,
a lot of the things
in traditional archives
simply don't get to the point.
For this show I didn't want
drawings or renderings,
but screenshots and forum posts.
If I'm trying to
focus on some aspect
of architectural culture
archival work becomes something
like anthropological fieldwork.
Part of the job is to scout
out possible archives.
So in this case if I care
about the impact of software
in architecture it makes me
wonder if we should be thinking
of archiving not only
old versions of software,
but things like change logs
and tech support
forums, for example.
The ambitious question
to ask here it seems
to me is how would we
archive digital culture?
One project I'm working on right
now is to collect snapshots
of entire computers and to save
them in sort of time capsules
that capture not only
specific projects,
but an entire way
of working, right?
These may or may not be
interesting a couple decades
from now as kind of
case studies, we'll see.
I'll end by noting a commonality
between the projects I showed.
My own privileged position
with direct access to files
and the people who created them.
My sort of final question here
is how can we set-up archives
that recreate as much
as possible this
privileged position
for every researcher
approaching an archive?
How can we allow a
feeling of direct access
or of a window onto a culture?
I suspect that this would
require a very particular type
of archive that we don't
actually see very often.
Okay, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Dennis Shelden: Okay,
so I think this is going
to be a good wrap-up.
I'm going to try to connect,
it actually turns out I'm going
to try to connect some of
the themes from this morning
around interoperability
and IFC and all that kind
of I guess BIM stuff
with some of the themes
from this afternoon,
including some systems
that normal humans use
and some of the stuff
that Andrew talked
about, but not as smart.
[laughter] So just very briefly,
yes, about me and the lab.
As Andrew mentioned, so before
I joined Georgia Tech I was
associated with Frank
Deerey's office
as the Technology
Director and then the CTO
of Deerey Technologies.
Produced a bunch of
different software,
I'll talk about one piece of it,
and then in parallel I've been
in academia both at MIT and
Georgia Tech and other places.
And the lab definitely focuses
on things like data standards
and interoperability,
also this kind
of general I think project
delivery systems may have come
up but how you connect tools,
organizations, data work and all
that kind of stuff and
then some automation stuff
and what goes on.
So I'm actually going to
talk about four use cases.
Two of them I'm not
going to talk about BIM,
IFC and open data
standards because I was told
that we had that
subject covered.
I'm going to talk
about two data systems,
one which was actually
Andrew's brainchild back
in Deerey Technologies, another
system which is a GSA project
that some of the audience may
know better than me, CourtsWeb,
which is about sort of
archiving design intent
of different courthouses.
And then two things that are
more about sort of the language
of design and if we can do
stuff to capture that, as well.
So, without further ado,
this is the first project
that I mentioned.
This is a system that was
developed actually originally
by Andrew when he was working
on the Louis Vuitton
project in Paris.
And the notion there
I think people talked
about Katia [assumed spelling],
I won't mention that too much
but this idea that
you have to manage,
with that system you have
to manage tens of thousands
of files that are
evolving asynchronously
by different stakeholders
across the world and sort
of managing versioning of
that and who did what and sort
of just dealing with that sort
of evolving asynchronous
compound document problem.
So the system was originally
conceived of as sort
of wrapping this set of files --
let's see, can I point with
anything -- but making those,
exposing those visually
on the web.
This is pretty early in the web,
you know, it wasn't that early,
but not everything
was on the web then.
But, more importantly, kind
of capturing the social
transactions that happen
between different players
as these models evolve
asynchronously over time.
So this is just a kind of an
early screenshot of kind of the
like what we call the feed
of different people working
on different components.
You could click through it
and you'd see the files.
This became a kind of
a more robust system,
which became a commercial
product called G Team.
I think I'm auto, yes,
okay, we'll just let it run.
Okay, which included
again this idea of kind
of the Facebook wall of the
project, who did what, when.
You could drill into that.
You had a file structure, as
well, because we needed that.
You could get the data on those
models, and then you could pull
up the kind of the
organization of those files
and it was very sort
of tree structured.
It's kind of a light version of
ISC, which is tree structured
as opposed to this big
complex hairball relationships.
But it did sort of wrap
all these different files
in the sort of social
transactions among players,
and I think that's an important
piece for at least to consider
when you're archiving
a project is the fact
that these transactions
are no longer happening,
this super rigid kind of
hierarchical structure
that we associate with
project contracts and delivery
but there's actually sort of
cross-pollination happening.
It's more of a web of
transactions than it is
like a hierarchy, so it was
kind of, you know, handled both
of those in kind of
an early fashion.
And just to kind of
close the loop, yes,
we sort of started
looking at this
as actually something you could
embed in social media, as well,
so you could take the
model at this state
and plug it into Facebook.
So that was kind of the
beginning of it at least.
And I guess I should say that
as the system evolved you could
upload files in native formats,
you could actually download them
in IFC and it stored it
in its own file format,
its own data format.
You could connect
different objects
to their associated objects,
like so here you have
a view that's tied
to a drawing, those
kind of things.
So these abilities to
kind of tie model objects
and transactions in different
digital assets I think this is
becoming possible now.
This became a commercial product
or got bought by Trimble,
who then and now it's known as
Trimble Connect and it's moved
on beyond that, and there
are certainly other systems
that do this, as well.
So that's a little
bit kind of back
to where we were this morning.
I wanted to point out another
project which isn't, you know,
I've had nothing to do with,
but it is done by the people
in the program at Georgia Tech.
And it's a project for
the GSA called CourtsWeb,
that's the link, but you
can just Google CourtsWeb.
Does anybody from the GSA
know about this project?
Okay, good, so I
can make stuff up.
[laughter] But essentially what
this is is an online database
of about 30 or 40
different courthouses
that have metadata associated
with those courthouses, images,
data associated with where
it is, who was the architect,
all that kind of good stuff.
And some analyses that I think
are the most interesting things.
So you can do comparisons, pick
a couple different courthouses
and see them together.
It has things like the
drawings in the 3D models,
but also a figure
background kind of views,
different analyses,
images of course.
And then maybe most
interestingly
as a segway 3D models that talk
about the different
circulation paths,
so from what I understand, you
guys may know better than me,
but courthouses have a very
sort of mission critical idea
about which different
constituencies,
I mean basically the
judiciary goes one way,
the public goes another way,
the indicted go a different way
and you have to keep
them separate.
And in a three space
configuration that's actually
fairly challenging, it's
challenging to understand, too.
So this system is I think
complementary to some
of the design guidelines
that would be associated
with courthouses and sort of
present an archive of some
of the critical things
that are in that guideline
and that the GSA and
the court systems care
about for those buildings.
So it's seen as kind of
a database and archive
of again different features
of those different projects
that you can compare.
So those are the two
kind of portal views
of this kind of digital
archiving.
And then from there I
want to quickly go to some
of the more rarified stuff
around design language.
So I thought this was an
original thought when I came
up with this slide,
but on the left --
okay, so on the left
obviously the Rosetta Stone,
in the middle Andrew talked
about Christopher Alexander
and pattern language, on
the right the court stuff
which isn't mine either.
And I think the point is, you
know, the point I want to make
about the Rosetta Stone is --
I guess are there any
linguists in the audience?
Okay, mostly architects.
So obviously the
purpose of an object
like the Rosetta Stone isn't
just to archive itself,
it's to serve as an archive
for all possible languages --
what do you want to
say, sort of sentences
or configurations associated
with those languages, right?
That's why it's so important.
So the question that
I think I would pose
and I think Andrew did
this a little bit, as well,
is can we not just
archive a specific object,
maybe it's been representation,
but get a little bit deeper sort
of in terms of the forensics
of understanding the DNA
of that particular
typology, right?
So what do all GSA
courthouses have in common?
How could you compare
them to each other?
Is there a way of
sort of qualifying
or quantifying those
features, right?
So there is some really
interesting research work
that is really about --
I'll just cut forward --
is about sort of understanding
the languages of design.
It goes by a special term
called shape grammars,
some of you may have heard of
this, but it really is sort
of a direct descendent of
computational linguistics.
And I guess I would
just compare these two
because this is worth
digging into a little bit.
I learned the diagram on the
left when I was in high school,
that probably dates me.
I should say I didn't learn
it, the English teacher brought
that up one afternoon,
nobody could figure
out what he was talking
about and he dropped it.
And I imagine a lot of you
have had a similar experience.
So Norm Chomsky, known for a
lot of important work but came
up with this epiphany
that really all sentences
are structured
as these binary decompositions.
So a sentence can
be decomponented
into its noun phrase and its
verb phrase, the verb phrase
in terms of a verb
and a noun, whatever,
a participle I think -- you guys
might know better than me --
and they sort of
cascade down, right?
There's this substitution
from a high level object
and its decomposition into
richer and richer sort
of substructures, right?
So if you tee it up
that way the idea
that there might be some sort
of way of decomposing a project
into its constituent
components and then further
and then further and
understanding that structure
as you go makes some
sort of sense
and that's really the basis
of the shape grammar
canon, if you will.
So left and right are two
examples I'll show you.
Let me see, let me
go to a specific --
well, here's the theory,
which is that it's
about again these substitutions,
every shape, every building,
every project can be decomposed
into replacement rules
that architects might replace
one thing with another.
I see a square, I rotate
it, blah, blah, blah.
I can find that shape
in my design,
I can do that replacement.
And so a lot of the work about
documenting, this has been done
with Frank Lloyd Wright
projects and Palladian Villas
and the list goes on and on,
but you can essentially sort
of archive that set of rules
and use it to play back
for all kinds of different
projects of that typology.
So here's some work
that ties directly
into the CourtsWeb project,
which is looking at
Meise courthouses.
As far as I understand
there's quite a few of them.
On the left are the
original sketches from Meise,
on the right are those
generated typologies
and those are generated by this
list of these substitution rules
that you can apply to take
the overall courthouse,
maybe split it up into,
Lord knows, the public
and the private and then
down to other refinements.
So even down to things
like actual construction
typologies, right?
So here's again that set of
rules being applied and the fact
that you can apply
to a whole bunch
of different possible
configurations
of this Meise courthouse.
Last thing I'll show you is some
work that actually is just part
of what I teach to all the
students at Georgia Tech.
And it's a little bit the same
idea and it's using Grasshopper,
which I think many of
you will know is a sort
of visual scripting
add-on to Rhino.
How many of you have
heard of Grasshopper?
Okay, and it's a very easy way
to do some of the crazy stuff
that Andrew was talking about.
So basically you can
generate scripts by dragging
and dropping these blocks and
then you make modifications
to the blocks and it
generates these forms.
But I think for me what's
interesting and what I try
to force the students to believe
is that you can actually use
that as a diagraming tool in and
of itself for the organization
of the logic of the projects.
And we do a number
of case studies
of historical projects
using these frameworks,
and there's kind of a high level
hypothesis that we actually,
that I brought from
Gary's work which says,
and this may sound
crazy or simple
or really dumbing it down.
But all projects
can be decomposed
into three high level systems,
the exterior volume of it,
the floor, top of floor
planes, top of slab planes,
and the structural grid.
And once you have those three
canonical systems you mix
and match them and then
you get sort of the frames
that the mullions go in,
the core goes in,
those kind of things.
So there is this kind of natural
hierarchy of all projects
of that decomposition and
just we actually can look
at some core templates and
how those things play out,
but we look at different
sort of typologies, towers,
grids, stadium, stations.
We actually give out
these little templates
and then the students
can kind of mix
and match those component
systems to sort
of plug-and-play
different configurations.
And here's an example of what
an undergraduate team did,
the Beijing Stadium.
Turns out, you know,
there is a very --
it's a great project
because it is a very --
it looks like a hairball,
but it's a very rational
top-down hierarchical system
of this ellipse with
the oculist,
the ribs that connect those,
and then that produces a set
of configurations that these
different subsystems can
go into.
And then so again we're using on
the bottom kind of the program
as the map and that
allows you to kind
of also decompose the project
into its constituent systems
and then, of course,
you can do kind
of generative reconfiguration
of that stuff.
So I think that's it.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Kurt Helfrich: So
now we'd like to be able
to have questions
from the audience.
Oh, come on now -- oh, okay?
>> On the emulation,
how far back can you go?
Can you go back to
greenscreens and VMS and?
>> Euan Cochrane: Okay,
so the way the emulation
as a service framework works
is it brings together a bunch
of emulators.
We just added another
one recently.
I think they also added the
EME granulator last year.
If there's an emulator for it
we can add it to the network,
and I believe there
are emulators for a lot
of the earlier machines.
We haven't added them because we
haven't had any use cases yet,
but as soon as there is
we can get the developers
to integrate them.
>> What about the systems
that had very different
display systems
or very different input devices?
>> Euan Cochrane: The display
systems are always going
to be a challenge.
And one of the things
we're looking
at from a research perspective
or actually I should say
the University of Freiburg
who developed the emulation as
a service framework are looking
at is how to access these,
the desktop environments
from mobile devices, which is
where so many people
access things these days.
And there may just be no way
to properly map old
displays to modern hardware.
One of the things
that I'm interested
in is accessing these
kind of things
in virtual reality environments
because you can simulate
whatever kind
of interface you wanted
in virtual reality,
and I have seen someone
that did that.
They made a virtual
reality environment
with an emulator backing the
computer sitting inside of it,
so you could use the
original computer
in the virtual environment.
The original hardware
was simulated.
It was really cool.
And input devices, what they can
do is they translate any input
to any equivalent
that is available
in the emulator theoretically
and they've done
that in practice.
They've done it for video
cameras and other sensors
that we use for digital
outworks,
so they've connected those
to the emulator version
of the hardware when the
original computer that was
on this digital outwork
installation died.
So they connected it
to the new computer,
which was running the emulation
and they translated
the sensor data camera
or like a motion sensor
I think was one of them
to the emulator environment
and it accepted
and used that input directly.
So if there's a way to
translate it to something
that means anything
to the emulator then I mean it's
all just coding, it just depends
on how much time and money
you want to put into it.
>> Ryan Donaldson:
Hi, Ryan Donaldson
with the Durst organization.
It's great to hear in these
examples of really being able
to bring to light
architectural practices,
to be able to make
them more engaging.
And my question touches
on kind of the response
to these projects and in
particular the emulation
and exhibitions that were done.
In terms of the emulation piece
is there any kind of measuring
in terms of almost the
performance that's going
on in terms of user experience,
being able to see what
they're going to and being able
to then inform further
work that you're doing?
And on the exhibition
side in terms of visitors
and visitor responses
and metrics around that?
Was that something that was a
part of the project, as well?
>> Euan Cochrane:
I'm sure that's a no,
but it's something
we've talked about.
And we can definitely,
we could add monitoring
of say where users click.
And, in fact, for awhile there
they had an implementation
of this that was used for doing
bulk migration between formats,
where you'd run a
migration on one file
and it would copy
your interactions
with a virtual computer and
you could just replay thousands
of files to migrate them
using the original software.
And so the technology is
there if we wanted to monitor
and interact with
these things we could.
And we didn't monitor
the use of the machines
in any way in the exhibition.
>> Yes, I mean I'll just say
that also, no, unfortunately.
You know, especially the last
exhibition I showed was meant
to be sort of embedded within
the community that sort
of that the work was showing.
And maybe not, let's say,
surveys or something like that,
but some way of creating
feedback and sort
of interactive displays
or putting
up your own post-it notes
or some more sophisticated
version of that.
Yes, if I were to do a
bigger version of the project
that would be exactly the
direction I'd go with it.
>> Jeffrey Ouelette, Vectorworks
and buildingSMART International.
So it goes back to the emulation
and you sort of threw it out
or threw it off, the problem you
face when you have applications
that used hardware
keys for protection
and how difficult
then that becomes
to then provide emulation
and continuity?
>> Euan Cochrane: There are
at least two organizations,
I believe Peter and Brendan
representing one of them,
that are looking at whether
we could get a DMC exemption
for breaking DRM.
There are ways to do it, whether
we're legally allowed to do it
or not is another question.
But you can emulate the
dongles and attach them
to the virtual serial
port or whatever.
>> Right, so really it's
more of a legal issue.
>> Euan Cochrane: But for
the most part it's still hard
to emulate them, someone has
to do that for every single one
and that's work, but
once you've done it once
that software can then be
used millions of times.
>> Hi, Elisa again from Stuckey.
My question, I have two, so I'll
start, is about the space --
I don't know the
actual words you used?
>> Shape grammar, I think.
>> Yes, exactly.
Thank you.
And the whole concept of
visual orders that goes
into that I think is really
important because from someone
who doesn't have an
architecture background,
which is not always the case
but it's often for archivists
who are going to be taking care
of these things afterwards,
there has to be some way for us
to be better educated in order
to be able to take on
these next days I think.
Because a lot of the rose-tinted
glasses and appreciation
of the paper-based drawings
you can just say these
are beautiful.
I understand, I grasp
why this is important.
>> Right.
>> And it's lost often when
you're looking at a black screen
with a bunch of neon
colored lines.
And so I'm wondering how do
we prepare ourselves for that
and if you think space
grammar is the way to go
or if there's something else?
>> Oh, God.
Well, let me start because
I think there's quite a bit
of answer to that.
I mean I'm not sure, I think
do you need to know linguistics
to be good at language?
No. Are most people
good linguists?
Probably not even if
they're good at language.
I think it's a useful technique.
I think it is very germane
to the historical forensics
and understanding of
past decision making.
It seems like -- what
am I struggling for --
it seems like it may
not just be a set
of abstract computational
technique,
it might actually be
something that is, you know,
could be seen as being human.
Certainly the people that
work on it believe that it is,
that it's part of the process
of design to recognize things
and replace them and that it is.
I'm certainly part of a
group that thinks that.
I'm a structuralist so I
believe that the structure
of language conditions what
we do as whoever we are.
So, but it's certainly
only one technique for kind
of discovering features
of and understanding,
retroactively understanding
designs.
>> Kurt Helfrich:
Well, with that,
I'm afraid we've
run out of time.
So thank you very
much to our panelists.
I think they gave
excellent presentations.
[ Applause ]
And, as well, I'd like
to acknowledge Grace,
our timekeeper who
has kept us on track.
[applause] At this point
we'll take a short break
and come back I think at three.
>> Yes, sure, come
back at three.
[break]
>> Stacy: As we start off and
wrap-up today I did want you
to please stick around because
we are going to have a summary
by Tim Walsh to wrap us up
and then also Kate will
be back to make comments.
But let me kick it off now for
our fourth session, please.
Thank you so much.
>> Kit Errington:
Okay, hi, everybody.
What a great day we're having.
Wow, I love the energy of
having to quiet everyone
down because there's
so much to say
and so many great
people to say it with.
So thanks, everyone,
for a great day so far.
I'm Kit Harington.
I work in the Prints and
Photographs Division here
at The Library of Congress, the
home for the 80 East Center.
I started here in 1995 and cut
my teeth, and I'm continuing
to work very hard today
on the historic American
building survey,
historic American
engineering record,
landscape survey,
fabulous collections
that started in 1933.
All of the access and styles
and sociology and history,
these collections are used
constantly this way today
and people are downloading
the images
and the drawings and
making 3D models.
Like it's in a live collection,
it's becoming more digital every
day, and we hope to continue
to be able to provide access
to it in those new ways.
So we've got the heroes
is what I'm thinking
of what this panel is.
We've had a lot of really
interesting challenges
that have been phased
and described,
and what these guys are doing
is the hard work of trying
to provide some of those
answers and solutions
of software and standards.
So we're going to be hearing
from Phil Rosche yet again,
wonderfully, from the
CAx Implementors Forum.
Jessica Meyerson, Software
Preservation Network,
SPIN I think is how
it is pronounced.
Jeff Ouellette is going to be
talking about smart building,
give us IFC information.
And Roger Grant from
NEBS is going
to be introducing some
standards information for us.
So welcome and let's
get started.
>> Phil Rosche: Well, as
you know, earlier I was kind
of filling in for Rick Zuray
of Boeing and, unfortunately,
that's not the first time
I've done that, but anyway.
[laughter] I'm going to talk
about something that's a bit
nearer and dearer to my heart,
which is interoperability
testing.
And, you know, that word
interoperability has become very
common I think in the
last or five or 10 years,
but I think it was the community
that I run in where it came from
but I'm taking credit
for it anyway.
[laughter] You started
to see translation software
built upon the steps standard
or based upon the
steps standard probably
in the '90s, the early '90s.
And actually big OEM companies
liked the Boeings of the world,
would actually develop their
own translation capability
for their CAD system.
And then finally you started
to see the actual software
companies developing this
translation capability, but none
of them worked very
well together
and the steps standard was
supposed to be straightforward
and unambiguous and all
these kinds of things
but these systems didn't
interoperate at all.
So, and actually I think I'd
said this a little earlier,
but myself and some other folks
in this industry got together
and we said, well, how
can we test this software?
And we didn't like those words
like compliant and conformant
and things like that
because I think if you look
out in the general software
industry there are certainly
examples of software that's
conformant or compliant
but not interoperable at all.
So interoperability
was our number one goal
in starting the CAx
implementor forum.
There's currently three
hosting organizations of it.
The organization
that I'm on contract
to is called PDES, Incorporated.
It's primarily an aerospace
and defense consortium.
Prostep is a project
under PDES, Inc.
Prostep ivip is I would call
them a German automotive
consortium, but they
probably prefer
to be called a European
automotive consortium,
heavy German influence.
And then AFNet, and don't
ask me what that stands for
and it's probably French anyway,
but they're kind of a trains,
planes and automobile
industry group of France.
But those are the
organizations that host us.
The group is composed
of computer aided design
and computer aided
engineering vendors
and also what we call
third-party vendors,
which are the translation
software vendors.
They don't, a third-party vendor
doesn't have any authoring
software, they just change
the gender of a native file
to a neutral file or
something like that.
It is a closed group,
we call it a sandbox.
We do not release results of a
particular vendor to the world
or to our member organizations.
The only results they see
are kind of rolled up,
so how well did we do
on geometric accuracy
or something like that.
And so it is a trusted
environment,
and I don't think
you see this much
in other software
development groups,
but you'll actually
see somebody from --
I'm just going to
make this up --
Deso Systems helping out
somebody from Siemens NX
or Solid Works or whatever, and
it's kind of a neat environment.
We launched this in '99,
that was kind of part
of the history lessons.
We've actually done 40 rounds
of testing on the CAD side
and we're just starting
on the CAE side,
and really our primary mission
is to meet industry's needs
by providing them with these
interoperable products.
I already said we test
on a closed environment.
We don't let any
specific results out.
All the participants are
testing alpha and beta software,
it's pre-production, so this
early detection of errors
in their software
actually provides them
with a faster development cycle.
One other thing that I think
is a big benefit of this is
that we actually
test the standard
as it's being developed,
and you'll see a
chart a little later,
but the current steps standard
we're working on is AP242
and it was as soon as
we had a data model
of AP242 we started testing
it and yet it's going
through the ISO ballot
process at the same time,
so it's not even an
international standard yet.
So we tested the standard
while it was being developed,
we provided input back to them
so that they could
improve the standard
and get rid of the bugs in it.
We call this CAx-IF on a page,
but up in the upper left there
we have the user companies
and then there are a broad
range of types of companies.
There are aerospace and defense,
there are automotive, you know,
shipbuilding, you name it,
but they kind of provide us
with their requirements.
And a relatively recent
requirement is that we have
to have geometric and
dimensional tolerances
in the step-based products.
So we go off and see how hard
that's going to be to do and see
if it's in the data
model, the group down there
in the lower left, the ISO.
And then we also get test
models from the user companies
to do our testing with,
and we go off and test it.
And so the user companies get
interoperable software back.
The standards groups they get
standardization issues fed back
to them.
And just to the general world
over there on the bottom right,
you know, they get
commercial products that work.
So I'm not going to spend any
time on this, this is kind
of the scope of AP242, but
it's all those kinds of things
that they use in a
mechanical design context.
And an important word there
is managed model based 3D
engineering, so it's
designed to be managed
by a PDM or a PLM system.
Again, it has all the
data necessary to do that.
And, like I said, this is the
kind of the history of AP242
and testing it, if you will.
And I think I said we were
on the 40th round of testing,
but the development of AP242
started at the end of 2010.
And along the left-hand side
those are all the various ISO
valid steps you'd
have to go through.
And so we've been testing
it all the way along,
and actually sometimes
we've actually been ahead
of the standard and we'll
see things that aren't
in the standard and we'll
just make up a data model
and stick it into the main data
model ourselves and go ahead
and test it and then feed that
back to the standards folks.
Regarding our methodology,
the steps standard uses both
express and XML schemas.
XML is primarily
used for what I kind
of consider the softer
stuff, the metadata
and the part number,
stuff like that.
And then we use the
express, it is primarily used
for the geometry and
the complex stuff
because express is a lot more
richer modeling language.
We also provide these documents
called recommended practices
documents, and it's kind
of a cookbook approach
on how you implement
the steps standards.
And, as I said earlier,
these standards were supposed
to have been unambiguous,
but obviously they weren't.
And there's a lot of
times in the standard
where there's multiple
paths you can take
or you don't really know what
kind of value is expected
or something of that nature.
So we write these recommended
practices documents based upon
discussion we have with
all the software developers
and it's an agreement,
if you will.
And then the test
case definitions.
When the vendor produces a step
file based upon a particular
functionality we test it for
syntax, so is it conformant
to the schema, and typically
that's kind of as far
as conformance testing goes,
just is it conformant
to the schema.
But we also test it for
structure and semantics,
and we kind of consider that
to be conformant to our --
and I don't like to even
use that word conformance,
but applicable or it lends
itself or it follows along
with the recommended
practices documents.
And actually we get a
lot of I think the IFC
and BIM folks have had a lot of
interaction with the NIST folks
over the years and kind of
the same help, if you will,
so and NIST helps
us out with this.
Anyway, so these step files
are submitted and they're found
to be good, and all the other
participants post-process t hem.
And we actually have an online
system for the participants
to go on and they enter
in data about the exchange
that they just did,
whether they're the native
or the target system, and
the system does an automatic
comparison and shows you where
issues are and things like that.
It's basically an Excel
spreadsheet on steroids.
And then a lot of times we
find issues during the testing
that are actually
resolved before the end
of that particular
round of testing.
The recommended practices
documents,
I mentioned there's one on how
to do business object model
assembly structure, geometric
and assembly validation
properties
and external references.
We provide a test case
specification at the beginning
of every round of testing.
Typically there's a number of
test cases in a test suite.
A test suite is the overall
document and there's a number
of test cases in it,
and sometimes it has modeling
instructions and it always talks
about what statistics are needed
by the statistic system we use.
There's just a screenshot of our
statistic system, like I said,
it's like a spreadsheet
on steroids.
There's a lot of
other things going
on in the step and
the AP242 realm.
NIST has an MBE validation
project going
on that we kind of feed on.
They also have a step
file analyzer that we use
and also provide feedback
to so they can improve that.
Besides our own implementor
forum there's also two other
implementor forums that are
kind of in the same realm
and there's a lot of
cross-pollination between them.
there's the JT implementor
forum, JT is a --
>> Phil, could you step
forward to the mike, please?
Thanks.
>> Phil Rosche: I'm sorry.
JT is kind of a semi-proprietary
visualization format
from Siemens, but they also
use the step data model
as the underlying structure
for like assembly structure
and the metadata
and stuff like that.
So we meet with them on a
relatively regular basis,
and also there's a
PDM implementor forum
but it's the PDM systems
implementing the steps standard.
And that's it.
[ Applause ]
>> Jessica Meyerson:
Hello, everyone.
Again, my name is
-- or not again --
my name is Jessica Meyerson.
I was a Digital Archivist at the
University of Texas at Austin
for five years before
taking my current position
with Educopia Institute and
there I conduct applied research
that advances understanding
of digital preservation
and scholarly communication
landscapes.
And I proudly serve the members
of the Software Preservation
Network and it is
in that capacity that I
get to join you here today.
And before I begin
allow me to express mine
and all SPIN participants
and collaborators' thank you
to The Library of Congress
and the tremendous work
of the organizing
and programming committee
for today's summit.
Sincerest thanks
to all of the staff
that have made this event
meaningful for the attendees
and thanks to all of
you for attending.
We're grateful for the
opportunity to be in dialogue
with you today and I want
to recognize Matthew Allen
for introducing me to
the work of Andrew Kovac.
All of the images that I
use today in the slides are
from Kovac' archive
of the affinities,
which I highly recommend.
There are citations for each
of the Tumblr citations,
for each of the images
included in the slides.
Okay, the first part of my
presentation is the case
for software as infrastructure.
So, well, a sneak preview.
So Susan Leistar, who is an
information infrastructure
scholar, sadly is
no longer with us,
wrote in a paper called The
Ethnography of Infrastructure,
quote, people commonly
envision infrastructure
as a system of substrates.
It is by definition invisible,
it's part of the background
for other kinds of
work, end quote.
Infrastructure is
a fundamentally
relational concept.
The cook considers the water
system as working infrastructure
and a role to making dinner,
while for the city
planner it's a variable
in a complex planning process
or a target for repair.
Star and her colleague completed
a study in the early 1990s
on an online community
called WORM, and concluded
that infrastructure has
several key characteristics.
So this is their model.
And I'm going to present the
case that software has all
of these characteristics with
examples where appropriate
from architectural design
and engineering
scholar-practitioners,
as well as much broader examples
provided by the cofounder
of Netscape, Mark Anderson,
in his 2011 article,
Software is Eating the World.
The examples still hold true
and, frankly, even more so.
So software is embedded,
it's sunk into and inside
of other structures, social
arrangements and technologies.
Anderson writes, more
and more major businesses
and industries are being
around software delivered
as online services from
movies to agriculture,
to national defense,
to global finance.
Mack U. Allen [assumed
spelling], reviewing
and exhibit entitled,
Architecture, Architectural
and Architecture with a capital
A, describes as evidenced
by the works included
in the exhibit how
software is not a part
of the specific workflow or
phase of architectural design,
but rather that it's embedded
into a creative work routine.
Software is transparent
and specifically
in this context meaning that it
doesn't have to be reassembled
or reinvented each
time or for each task,
but that it invisibly
supports those tasks.
Anderson writes, on the backend
software programming tools
and internet based
services make it easy
to launch new global
software powered startups
in many industries
without the need to invest
in new infrastructure
and train new employees.
Software has reach and scope,
beyond a single event
or one site practice.
Anderson writes, software
is also eating much
of the value chain of industries
that are widely viewed
as primarily existing
in the physical world.
Software runs engines, it
controls safety features,
it guides drivers
to destinations,
it powers logistics and
distribution capabilities
of FedEx, Walmart and the like.
As is evidenced by discussions
here today the built environment
often begins in a
software environment.
Software is learned as
part of a membership,
so similar to the
art of drafting,
specific planning documentation
for the built environment
and different forms of modeling
certain types of software
or specific uses of
that software are part
of the repertoire
of a profession
or a community of practice.
Software is the embodiment
of standards,
so speaking to Katie's
analysis in her dissertation
of architectural
practice as associated
with technical system, a
practice has specific needs
and standardized
workflows or business rules,
some of which can be translated
into the functional requirements
of software applications.
These applications as
embodiments of standards
and conventions have their own
impacts on the daily practice
as they are adopted and adapted.
The use and reuse
of these software
and resulting digital objects
may shape the need or demand
for changes or enhancements
to the software in the future.
Software is built on
an installed base.
All new infrastructure
wrestles with the inertia
of the installed base.
Software is always wrestling
with existing practices,
user expectations and tools.
Software is fixed in
modular increments,
not all at once or globally.
Because software
exists in a universe
of dependencies you're
always pursuing a fix
that is the most well contained
or most loosely coupled
to everything else.
The fix for the Windows XP users
during the WannaCry ransomware
event in May 2017 was a patch,
not a comprehensive upgrade
for those users from
XP to Windows 10.
What is the smallest
change we can make
that will repair the
system or bring it back
into an operational state?
Because of this software is
in a state of ongoing repair.
And then finally software
becomes visible on breakdown
and this is what
will problematize.
And I don't know
if you can see it,
but the infrastructure is
showing in that photograph.
It got cut-off a little bit.
Your infrastructure is showing.
[laughter] So software
can break, it has bugs,
but breakdown doesn't
map as well as the others
because software is so embedded.
So to use Anderson's words
consumptive of all structures
in industries that we
can't decouple the software
from other substrates in
the system including users,
the network, the regulatory
framework and the industry.
I argue that what we mean
by software breakdown
in today's context is
much bigger than that.
It's better understood
as the access breakdown
or the inability to
support meaningful access
to digital information.
This could be reproducible
science
and social scientific research
or as McKenzie Smith wrote
in her 2012 article for AIA
Online, quote, the need to refer
to an old design, consult
a change order or ASI
from a completed project,
or consider an addition
to an old building, end quote.
The access breakdown reveals
or makes visible the social
structures and practices
in which the software
is embedded.
I'll repeat that, the
access breakdown reveals
or makes visible the social
structures and practices
in which the software
is embedded.
The access breakdown is
a comprehensive breakdown
of social structures to
support information access,
communication, legal
systems and the market.
And when these social structures
breakdown they produce
and necessitate system
level change.
So a little bit more about
the access breakdown.
Our cultural record is
increasingly made-up
of complex digital
logics as evidenced
by discussions here
today, which are coupled
to software both proprietary
and nonproprietary.
And I really, really,
really, really,
really wish that I could go
into this software
preservation history,
but this is a timeline
that's complementary to all
of the amazing work that
Elisa and Tim and Katie shared
with you earlier today,
that looks at the history
of just the software
preservation discourse and just
in information science,
computing history,
and the archives.
So our culture is
increasingly made-up
of complex digital
objects or what Peterson,
Trudy Huskein Peterson [assumed
spelling] to be exact, termed,
quote, software dependent
in 1985.
Evidenced by the 30
plus year discourse
and information studies,
history of computing
and cultural memory preservation
alone, and that's not
to say there aren't other
discourse of communities talking
about this for a long time.
The access breakdown, like
most infrastructure breakdowns,
is relatively to software
slow in the making.
So the access breakdown
necessitates system level change
that acknowledges
software as infrastructure.
System level change, so in 1995
Liam Bannon [assumed spelling]
posted a short piece in ACM
called, The Politics of Design.
Quote, the development
of computer based applications
requires the collaboration
or involvement of a variety
of distinctive communities,
workers with different
skills using different
representational frameworks.
This poses a number of
problems which can't be removed
by simply ensuring
good communication.
He argues it's more
fundamental than that,
it arises out of different
practices of the groups.
So how to construct a shared
or common information space
among these groups is seen
as a central concern.
Collective impact is a model
for understanding
system level change.
Collective impact has
five distinct components.
The common agenda, so engaging
all of the stakeholders
around a problem area
and helping them to come
to an agreement upon a common
vision or goal for change.
Shared measurement and data
that helps each group determine
what specific incremental steps
it can take to continue forward
progress at the system level.
Mutually reinforcing activities
that meet the vested interest
in economic drivers of
each stakeholder group
and the system, itself.
Constant communication
and refining of goals
of the stakeholders, both
individually and as a system.
And a lightweight backbone
comprising focused facilitators
providing the necessary
connection work.
The Software Preservation
Network is building capacity
to serve as a lightweight
backbone organization
that embodies and supports
a collective impact approach
to software preservation.
SPIN was first discussed in a
public forum in 2014 as an idea,
an idea that was conceptualized
as a logical extension
of the work spanning that
roughly 30 plus years
that had come before, including
the Preserving EXE Summit hosted
at the LOC in 2013.
SPIN believes that software
is important to preserve
because it is information
in and of itself,
as well as a dependency to
access other digital objects.
So the common agenda or mission
that unites SPIN's participants
and supporters is
to preserve software
through community engagement,
infrastructure support
and knowledge generation.
SPIN defines software
preservation
at the network level
as basically five core
activity areas necessary
for successful software
preservation.
So the first of these
is research,
so the research working group
in SPIN is currently creating
a toolkit that people can use
to gather data about software
preservation and curation,
upstream, downstream, that's
all in the scope here,
in their local communities.
These shared measurements
and associated data establish
and understanding of
the problems faced
as it shifts over time.
The training and
education group is working
on two major initiatives,
the translation
of their peer working
group's findings
into educational materials,
as well as a series
of software curation
recommendations and guidelines
for data curators and data
management professionals.
The metadata and
standards group sent
out a survey earlier this
year to provide a baseline
of metadata being
used to describe
and manage the preservation
of an access to software,
and based on those findings
even in institutions
that actively collect software
with policies and agreements
in place they're
still struggling
with issues pertaining to
standards, best practice
and preservation workflows.
The legal policy group is
focused on legal research
and advocacy pertaining to
copyright and licensing,
so this includes the
various best practices,
work that Euan mentioned
earlier that Brendan
and Peter are very
actively pursuing.
This also includes the 1201
exemption, so SPIN has partnered
for the last two or so years
with the Cyber Law Clinic
at the Brookman's Client
Center for Internet
and Society at Harvard.
And then on 2018, in 2018
we're looking to expand
to a comparative legal study
that looks at similar approaches
in two different
national contexts.
The technological infrastructure
working group is starting their
data gathering at
the consortial level,
this is digital preservation
consortial level,
to understand what existing
digital infrastructure
organizations already
have in place
to support storage preservation
access and sharing of software
and metadata associated
with software.
And then the communication
working group
and the governance working
group are all doing the work
to support those other
five core activity areas.
We also have affiliated
projects.
There are currently two
already funded and underway
that are focusing on areas
that we feel are really
important with one in tow.
So those areas would be
broadening participation
in this work, establishing
the various best practices
for software preservation, and
scaling access to emulation.
This is a mostly up-to-date
list of organizations, projects
and programs represented
in SPIN's membership
and activities.
As you can see, a lot
of these or if not all
of these are cultural memory
institutions of some sort.
We do have a couple
of different firms
and we have Software
Heritage, which is focused
on source codes, specifically
research source code.
So we have some variation
and we're working
on that representation.
So partner with the
Software Preservation Network
and let's save software
together.
[ Applause ]
>> Jeff Ouellette: Okay, thank
you all for hanging in there.
An ultimate presentation, okay,
one left to go after mine.
[laughter] I am so happy
you're hanging in there,
though, we've been jamming.
Well, Tim is -- you
do the wrap-up, right?
We're still jamming information
down their gullets, right?
I think it's interesting
I have to come all the way
to Washington, D.C. to meet
two fellow Austin, Texanites.
It happens all the time.
I'm actually here
as a representative
of buildingSMART International.
Also, in my fulltime job,
which sometimes prevents
my work getting done,
is with Vectorworks.
We're a software
vendor, we're based just
up the road in Columbia.
And I get to see people
like Greg Schloizner [assumed
spelling], Roger Grant,
Christine Falon, there are
many of us who are associated
with buildingSMART, both
locally or nationally
and internationally to
sort of promote and put
into practice some of
the ideas I'm going
to talk about right here.
So hang on, here we go.
All right, so I want to talk
about who is buildingSMART
International, what is IFC,
which is one of the standards
that we deal with, and why,
why should we worry about IFC,
why should we be
concerned about it.
So his buildingSMART
International?
Simple as this, it's
an international home
of OpenBIM, okay?
What do we mean by OpenBIM?
When we talk about BIM we talk
about building information
modeling.
When we talk about OpenBIM what
we're trying to do is remove
that proprietary
layer, we're saying
that the data is more important
than the tools, themselves.
And so as architects, as
engineers, as designers,
as owners, as operators
we should have access
to that information in a
way that's completely free
of any particular tool so that
we can move it from tool to tool
and operate with that
information as we need.
So as an organization
buildingSMART is international
and it's supported by the
chapters all over the world,
and I believe we're
actually up to 18 now,
there's about 15 showing there.
Russia just actually
started their own chapter.
And most of these chapters
are nationally based.
The Australasian chapter
includes Australia
and New Zealand and
also Tasmania,
a couple others out there.
And then the Nordic countries
have a Nordic chapter
that is also broken down
into one for each country.
But the idea is is that
we see a perspective
of the building industry
across the entire globe.
And this is one of the
things I want to emphasize
in this talk is dealing
with an expanded context.
I think a lot of times when
we get together in symposiums
like this and talks about this
we really sort of hyper focus
on an immediate market
or immediate problem.
And what we hope to do with
buildingSMART is to get people
to understand that there
is a larger context,
that this is a problem lots
of people face in many parts
of the world, if not
all parts of the world,
crossing multiple languages
and cultures and practices.
And so that input is necessary
in order to create standards
that work well for everybody
or at least baselines
in which everybody
can built upon.
And there are a number of people
that are involved that belong
to this organization
to run the organization
and promote these ideals and
to develop the standards.
And the three core programs
we work on are things
like standards, users
and compliance.
By standards that's
developing things we'll see
in the next slide.
By users it's an
international user program,
we're actually engaged
with practitioners,
we have to bring them to the
table to, A, educate them
about what the standards are and
why they're useful and then, B,
how to use those things and, C,
get input back from those people
to understand what are
the best ways to mature
and move those forward.
And then finally
there's compliance.
Like Phil was talking
about with the CAx Forum,
we have certification
of software to be able
to exchange this data using
IFC, which we'll talk about.
We have that certification
program that does that.
So in the building industry
there are applications
that have been certified
to be able
to exchange information
with each other.
The challenge is getting
end users to understand that
and to actually utilize it.
And then we're also
launching soon a professional
certification which says,
hey, I not only understand BIM
but I understand OpenBIM
at a professional level
as an individual but
also as a business level
and an organization level.
So buildingSMART is a
conglomeration of companies
and organizations that
are putting their money
where their mouth is.
At different levels of
support and sponsorship
in many different parts
of the world they're saying this
matters to us, we see the value
of trying to provide
standards for the industry
across all the different
processes,
and so we're putting money
in in order to fund all
of the activities
that are necessary
for this to move forward.
And essentially what do we do?
So simple as this, we develop
and maintain open
international standards for BIM.
As I said before, how do we
remove that proprietary layer
from the exchange of data?
And there are three main
or three core standards
that we really deal with.
Information delivery manual
which essentially is how do
you establish the business case
for exchanging data or
storing this data, right?
Greg was alluding to this
earlier about there has
to be a business
value, that makes sense.
So if we can establish what
those business values are then
we can begin to build the
standards and the technology
that then support
all of those values.
The industry foundation classes
is really the technical part
of our standards, and this is
the technical specification
or the data model for
that free exchange.
And then there's the
international framework
for dictionaries, or as Roger
will talk about this idea
of the buildingSMART
data dictionary,
is how then do we cross all
of these cultural and market
and language lines to
have common understandings
of what building elements are
and what materials are so that
when somebody says it in one
language we know immediately
through translation what it
means in another language.
And that's no small
thing because we live
in a global market now, right,
we are in a global industry,
we get parts from all
other parts of the world.
We can have designers
from multiple parts
of the world working together.
So we have to have those
layers of understanding.
And it's not just about design,
this is about the entire
lifecycle of the building.
In effect a reiterative
lifecycle of the building
in which when you come
to decommissioning,
the end of the lifecycle
of a building,
if we can gather enough data
about that building's
performance over its lifecycle
that gives us more
information to then turnaround
and do a better job
on the next building.
Or decide what do we do with
all of those old assets,
can we recycle them, can we
reuse them, if we download them
where are they going to?
We can capture a lot
of information throughout
the entire lifecycle.
And buildingSMART International
as an international organization
is a standards organization
and works through multiple
organizations primarily
at the top ISO, right?
This all exists internationally
because of ISO, but we also work
with other national
standards organizations.
So, for example, in a regional
sense we deal with CEN,
which deals with all of Europe,
but then within CEN
you have things
like the British standards
and you have the
German DIN standards.
And when something is accepted
at the ISO level it
trickles on down.
Now we also get things
from ISO in order
to feed the IFC standard and
step is one of those, step,
IFC is actually a derivative of
step and we use XML, we use X3D,
these are all other
ISO standards that feed
into what we're doing so that
we're not really reinventing the
wheel, we're using best
practices and best standards
that are already out there.
And in the end what
you really need
to understand is
buildingSMART are people.
So this is a photo that
was taken just a couple
of weeks ago in London.
Greg is in there somewhere.
Roger is in there somewhere.
Where we all got together and
we talk about these issues,
we talk about what are ways
to improve the coverage
of IFC throughout the
built environment?
What are the use cases
for exchanging data
between different stakeholders?
You know, what are
these projects
that we can bring together and
make it more useful for people?
How do we promote it to
the rest of the world?
Okay, so as I said,
three main standards.
The one I really want to
talk about today is IFC
because in this context
of how do we preserve
information this is the one
that matters really the most.
So IFC in its essence
is just a description
of the built environment
that's open public standard.
It's nonproprietary, no vendor
owns it, can control it, right?
It belongs to the world.
It's free to access.
And the whole idea is that
in that description it's
about geometry and
information, not data,
because the data side just
once told me he says data is
for computers, information
is for people.
It's context, it's semantics.
So if I look at an example of
a piece of geometry I can look
at it and say, well, what is it?
This means nothing, it looks
like something, but
I could guess.
And what IFC does is it has data
structures in there that says,
okay, well, as geometry is this
a solid or is it a surface,
you know, what level of
complexity of it is there?
What is it, what is
it in relationship
to how we think of buildings?
Is it a column, is it
a duct, is it a pile,
is it a piece of a wall, right?
And then what are
the attributes,
what are the properties to
it, how do I identify it?
What are its physical
attributes?
What is its performance
values, and how do we use
or how do we classify it in
terms of these other systems
when we do the costing
or mapping to systems
for tracking processes, right?
And then what are
the relationships?
When then I can see, I can
determine is something external
to the building or
internal to the building.
Is it being supported by or is
it supporting something else?
Is it within a particular room?
Is it within a particular wall?
So then I can say, hey,
this particular piece
of geometry has all of
this data attached to it,
it has an understanding of
what it is and I can query it
and I can look at it and
I can get a better sense
of what's going on
and what it is.
But it even stretches out to
understand the built environment
as we understand the
built environment.
There's a project level,
there's the site level,
there's the building level,
and then there's all the pieces
that become a part of it.
And it's not just about objects,
but it's also about this idea
of controls, of performance
history, of processes,
of the people that are
actually assigned or a part
of these objects
and these processes.
And it's more than
just buildings now.
We're currently in a
phase where we're looking
at describing the
entire built environment.
Infrastructure is now being
worked on by multiple countries,
describing roads, bridges,
railways, tunneling.
We're not going to
stop at buildings.
And this has been
going on for some time,
so over 21 years,
31 years, oh, jeez.
And it began with an alliance
with Autodesk and trying
to determine how
do they get data
between all these different
permutations of the platform
and has turned into
something greater than that
and involves a lot of
different people and a lot
of different applications.
IFC can be expressed
in multiple ways.
We're talking about
the step file,
but there's also using
computer science best practices
as being able to exchange this
information using XML formats.
And being able to zip these
things up into containers
that can be exchanged
more efficiently.
But the future is
looking even better.
It's really amazing as we look
at what computer science
has done over the last 10
to 15 years, how can we apply
that to what we're trying
to do with our data?
When can we get to the point
where we're no longer talking
about file exchange,
but we're simply talking
about querying tool to tool and
we're streaming data around,
where we're saving all
of it somewhere or linked
in multiple places
and we're able
to bring information
together at that point of use
and the point of need?
So we're beginning to follow
along what's happening
in the greater computing
industry
to really mature the
standard and how we use data.
And in the end it's the
best way to communicate
to building data
globally without barriers.
There's no other option
really out there that gives us
that ability of determining
semantics and context
and description and processes.
And we're doing this because
the software industry globally
is large.
I know there's a lot
of talk about vendor A,
I hear this all the time, right?
You can imagine how many of
these conferences I go to
and it's all about this,
it's all about this.
Yet if I look globally
there are hundreds,
over a thousand different
software companies
that serve all of their markets
very well with many users,
and they all have data that
needs to work together in order
to accomplish the idea of
designing, procuring, building
and operating buildings.
Because if I work on this
as a tool centric methodology
it requires a lot of work
for one vendor to connect to
a bunch of different vendors.
And instead what we need to do
is we need to turn this model
from being tool centric
into being data centric
because this is expensive
for a developer
to do, it's very expensive.
So if I move the model
from application centric
to content centric I may do
about the same amount of work
to get two applications
to talk to each other,
but when I get beyond
that one-to-one relationship
it becomes more difficult
for somebody.
And if I'm dealing with many
partners that are trying
to speak to each other there's a
lot of work that has to be done,
and then lots of
things are broken
as each individual person
revises their content
or revises their applications.
So if we're all working
on establishing
or supporting a single standard
we all do the same amount
of work and in the end what
we're doing is were doing less
work, we're lowering
the threshold for more
and more people to come
in and utilize that data
and be valuable to the process
and we're creating a larger
ecosystem for the end users,
for the market who want this
data, who want these tools
to do more and more stuff.
Because in the end what
happens is if we rely
on a tool centric model, if
you invest into a platform
and that platform doesn't
contain certain functionalities
that are necessary for
your business process
that means you don't do them.
Now is that acceptable?
If you were to say, hey,
you can buy a Ford vehicle,
but you can't drive on
any of the interstates,
would that be acceptable?
So why do we accept that
in the building industry?
And owners and designers need
to turnaround and force us
as vendors to say you
need to support this
because our data is more
important than your tools are.
So the whole point is this
is about creating value
in the data, that
you own the data
when it's open format, right?
Otherwise you have to have an
explicit agreement with each
of your vendors and if you stop
paying the vendors you stop
having access to that data.
Every owner should hear
that statement and go is
that acceptable,
is that acceptable?
If you can't access it 10 years
down the road what was the point
of even aggregating all
of it in the first place?
So you have that
ability, it has longevity.
And as a standard that we
provide we're also providing
this ability to making
it extensible.
You can keep building
on that data over time.
We don't have these radical
changes in the standard
that says, oh, well, now
like miniCAD 5 I can't open
in VectorWorks 2019, it's
almost impossible to do.
But with IFC files, with these
IFC standard I can always build
tools on top of those old
IFC files and access them.
So for more information
go to buildingsmart.org,
there's a technical site
that deals with developers,
and those who are
interested contact me,
I'd love to tell you more.
[ Applause ]
>> Roger Grant: Hello, and
thank you for the opportunity
to be here to share
some thoughts,
ideas and some work with you.
I'm Roger Grant.
I'm the Program Director
at the National Institute
of Building Sciences or
some people know us as NIBS.
We are a nonprofit
here in Washington,
D.C. that was created by the
Congress, but we are funded
from work we do primarily for
Federal agencies to help them
with their building programs,
a whole range of things
from how do you respond
to earthquakes,
to how do you manage the
information in your building.
So I'm going to talk
about that aspect of it.
As Jeff said, I'm also involved
with buildingSMART
International.
I lead the Product Room at
buildingSMART International,
and our primary focus is
on all the information
that really sits outside of
models, but contributes a lot
to the building process,
standards, specifications,
procurement information,
data or information
about all the products
that go into buildings.
So I'm going to be coming
from those two contexts.
This is out of the National
BIM Standard and since we're
at a library I thought we should
have a good definition of BIM.
So you can find this at the BIM
Standard, but it's pretty good
for one sentence about
what we're trying to do
with information across the
lifecycle and functional
and physical characteristics
of a building.
So I know we're here to
talk about archiving,
but I think what Jeff was
referencing was how we use
standards to organize
information, and I'm going
to talk about that
aspect of it, too.
I think of we don't have well
organized information it makes
the problem of archiving it and
reusing it a lot more difficult.
So most of our work is really
focused on how do we organize
and get value out of information
and apply it to solve problems.
I'm going to go through a couple
slides here real quickly to kind
of set it up, and then I'm
going to share some use cases
of projects we've
worked on for agencies
where they have been
implementing some
of these concepts.
And so this is, you know, I just
want to point out that a model
and IFC gives us a
structured way to do this,
but the good thing about a
model is it consists of objects
and those objects
have properties.
And once you've identified
those things as the key aspect
of a building you can attach
a lot of other things to them.
You can structure the
properties in an organized way.
You can put identifiers on
them that let you find them
in all kinds of other
applications.
You can embed specifications
that say more about it
in language that
people can understand.
You can connect it to
external information.
So that's the interesting thing.
And the model, we spend
a lot of time looking
at how do you replicate
the graphics that were done
in all kinds of different
systems?
But a lot of the value in
using models is in the data
or the information that
gets attached to them.
It's not trivial to think
about the information, itself,
and I've borrowed
this from Kimono Numa,
who works with us on
a lot of projects.
And the idea that platforms
and separating information
from the applications is
critical, and we're sort
of viewed as being behind
in the building industry
and I think that's relatively
well accepted in our adoption
of technology, but we can
look to others like Telcom
and what they've been
able to do and think
about how it applies to us.
You know, inside owner
organizations there's tons
of valuable information,
but it's in databases
that were created years
ago, they have structures
that have gotten a little
out of whack over time.
But it's still there and
a lot of it is good data
and if you can reorganize
it, apply some standards
to it you can make
it a lot more useful.
The key thing is starting by
separating the information
from the applications, the key
information that is valuable
to how you run your business.
I'm not going to say
too much about this,
but other than to say
this is a way to be able
to preserve information if you
have it logically organized.
And a lot of it is tabular data,
it's data about the
things that you're doing.
It's nice to represent it with
models and there's some things
that you can't do
without a model,
but a lot of it is
about the data.
And also in the case of the
Government it's real important
to use standards because
you can't be proprietary
about the tools you request.
So if you have an open
standard you can reference that
and you can ask for tools
that comply with it,
and that's really important.
There's another important
thing on that slide was legacy.
We're never going to
remake every legacy system
to follow a standard, but if
it's structured well enough
that we can map standards
to it then we can share it
with all the other processes
that are out there that we want
to connect to and then I
think we can also have a way
to keep track of it over time.
We need the information to
be useable, that's important,
but useable is a lot different
in a lot of different context.
I mean if I want to say this is
a space what do I need to know
about it, but if I also want
to capture the lighting
requirements and the air changes
and everything in it
we need different kinds
of information to do that.
But without the information
we can't make good decisions,
so we really want to figure out
how do we organize information
in a way that can support the
decisions that we need to make
and give us the ability to
make it useful over time,
not just in one sense.
And I guess I put this on
here because, I don't know,
what are we trying to solve?
Well, at the end of the
day we're really doing this
because we want to make things
better and more efficient.
I mean it's fun to talk about
computers and how they work,
but if we can't lower cost,
if we can't use less resources
in the environment it probably
doesn't matter all that much.
And so the Brits are kind
of an interesting study
because they have one
agency that manages building
for the whole Government
and they take a macro view
of how the building industry
supports everything they're
doing, and they have
set targets,
they've got this whole
program on level one,
level two, level three BIM.
BIM is at the core
of it for them
to make their processes better,
and they've actually
upped their targets
on what they think they
can do to lower cost,
to make their country more
productive, to reduce emissions.
So it's just good to keep in
mind why we're doing this stuff.
I don't have to talk about this
because Jeff did a good job
of describing the
buildingSMART standards.
But one thing is to get your
information organized in a way
that it's logical and
you can access it.
The next thing is to
apply standards to it
so others can efficiently
utilize your information.
It's one thing to
organize it for yourself,
but it's another
thing to open it
up so others can
use it efficiently.
So what we've been
trying to do is look
at how can we apply
buildingSMART's standards
in some kind of a process
so that we could replicate.
And we've been experimenting
with this
on several projects now.
Somebody said there's no one
solution and that's really true,
and you'd have to experiment
to find a good solution.
But IFC is the best way
to document buildings,
and there's some
connected processes, IDM.
It's important to know what
you're trying to accomplish,
where it fits into the bigger
picture, IDM lets you do
that by having a process map
and defining exchanges
of information.
And then within the realm
of IFC there's a way
to document those exchanges
so that they can be captured
in software, and that's really
important because we don't want
to do this stuff with
pencil and paper.
We want to automate
it and digitize it.
And we think it's also, we think
every exchange should have a
specification that says
what you're trying to do,
who wants the information,
who is the sender,
who is the receiver.
And what is it, if
there's a dictionary,
a data dictionary associated
with it that tells you
in multiple languages, because
this stuff is being used
and reused all over the
world, what's in that exchange
and then you can put
that into applications.
And we can do a better job of
standardizing these processes.
I guess Greg said,
what's the business case?
Well, the business
case is we have
to invest a little more
upfront to save a little more
on the backend, and that's
really in the owner's realm.
So I think where a lot
of the opportunity comes
to push this forward is for
owners and they're the ones
who also need to archive this
information about these assets.
So the first use
case I want to talk
about is some work we
did for Federal Highway.
They were trying to say how
can we have a standard for how
to get digital models
of bridges, you know,
every piece of infrastructure
in the contract?
You deliver a drawing that
says the requirements on it,
but if we want to move to
modeling we need a way to do
that that is standardized,
that can be replicated,
that's not based on one
vendor's software solution.
And so they were
looking at options.
We explored using the IFC,
the buildingSMART tools
as the foundation for this.
We developed an IDM that for
the entire bridge construction
process we focused on
one of the exchanges,
designed to construction.
We, importantly, took
some real examples
and actually modeled them
and developed the
requirements from real examples.
So really it's important
to begin at the end
and work your way backwards,
and that's what this project
gave us the ability to do.
We were able to develop
a process map
and the exchange specification.
We worked with Georgia Tech,
we worked with a specialist
in modeling and within IFC.
And now this project is
continuing to move forward.
AASHTO is picking
up the development
of a national standard,
they have projects
going now in this realm.
So we're talking a lot
about documenting buildings,
but documenting infrastructure
is really important
if we're going to add all
kinds of services on top of it.
And one interesting thing in
the infrastructure market,
there's 50 owners of our
infrastructure assets
in this country, there's
not 50,000 like there are
for buildings or
500,000 or whatever.
So they have some power to
consolidate what's going on.
And there's a lot
happening worldwide in this,
so there's a lot
they're borrowing from.
So in the building realm
we only have process,
we don't have a process
map for buildings
but the buildingSMART
alliance is working on it.
So I just put this in here,
I don't have time to talk
about it, but we need to be
able to know what's the process
and what are the exchanges.
And inside of a process are
these uses, and it's important
to also define the
uses that you want
to have processes to support.
So these were developed by,
identified by Penn State --
put them on this slide.
And so this is another
project for Defense Health
in the Veteran and VA to take --
space management is
very important for them
and equipment management in
their facilities so they need
to identify the spaces and
what equipment goes into them.
This was all in PDF documents.
We worked with them with
Anuma to convert this to data,
take all the information out of
the PDFs, put it into databases,
and also expose it
to their consultants
so they could get access to the
requirements from a web service.
It's all posted on max.gov,
and this tool you can look
at it online helps you to
organize that information
and parse it out so it
can be put into models.
It's got an equipment database
connected to it, as well.
I'm kind of giving you
a quick overview here
because I'm going
to run out of time.
But we're also working
on projects
for the Department of State.
They have an interesting
challenge,
they have a worldwide portfolio
of like over 12,000 assets
and missions in multiple
countries
that speak multiple languages,
and they have an
ongoing building program,
so how do they organize
all of that?
So we've focused on
several of these use cases
as a starting point,
in particular space planning
is real important to them,
and we started to look at
how they do space measurement
and there's a number of
different ways to measure space.
And so you see that when
you look at the results
in different systems and
there's also a number
of different ways you
might name things.
And all of our organizations
over time, you know, we develop,
we get different
names for things,
and actually naming
is real important
as a fundamental starting point,
but just having it consistent
in a way that you can --
and put it in someplace
that you can say this
is the source of truth
and then you can point the
rest of your organization to it
and you can start
to build on it.
So this is really the
starting point, and we've gone
through this by looking
first at, you know,
to get space organized we've
gone through this process,
look at coordinated, the
standards and the guides
about the information, look
at now we'll apply industry
standards, we'll continue
to do that, but first let's
get the information organized.
It's then developed
ways to communicate
out to your consultants so that
comes in through execution plans
and documents that
your contract documents
and those need to be updated.
And we also want to move,
and Jeff mentioned this,
to being able to validate.
Having a specification
for information let's you
automate the validation process,
and I think the whole area
of design review is one
that we need to continue to
evolve to move away from,
to move to its much
automated designer view
as we possibly can.
Of course, we need
to train people,
but the end result is we can
rationalize what we call things
and how we measure things
and communicate that
and have it work a
lot more efficiently.
I'm not going to talk
about COBie at all,
but COBie is an excellent way.
It uses IFC, it's widely used,
it's a way to organize
information.
But I do want to spend a little
time just sharing with you
about a use case we've
worked on for GSA.
GSA has been working
on BIM for a long time
and how to implement it.
They've got a lot of guides,
they did the first information
exchange specification
for spatial program
validation that's been in use.
And we've been recently
working with them
to move this concept further
along, and we've been working
on a use case for
energy analysis
to say our buildings use energy,
we have baseline standards,
we have modeling of energy and
design, energy uses and design.
And then when the building
is operated we have actual
energy usage.
But all that stuff is relating
back to the same systems,
and so if we can put together
a model to evaluate that,
that could be valuable for
operating the building.
So we did a process
model of this.
We took an 8-story real building
that had lots of systems in it
and we used that
as a case study.
Then we mapped the ASHRAE
90.1 as the baseline standard,
EnergyPlus for building,
for doing the modeling,
and Project Haystack
for the controls data,
and we mapped all that to IFC.
So now there's a specification
for how a model needs
to be configured to
provide, there will be,
for how to provide the data
for doing analysis and also
for measuring once the
building has been put
into operation, the meter data.
So GSA plans to share the
specification for this
at some point once the
project is completed,
and I think it'll be
an interesting thing
that can be reused.
I know I'm almost out of time, I
know I'm virtually out of time,
but I'm going to just do a
couple more quick things.
So that I really talked about.
And this idea of having
a process is important,
and I think this is something
that needs to continue
to evolve, but how do we define
requirements, how do we publish,
extend and implement it in
software and then validate it.
So this is what we're
basing these projects on.
And the other important
thing is having a place
to archive information
that you've produced
so it can be accessed by others.
And so at NIBS we have
the National BIM Standard,
which holds the COBie
exchange and other exchanges,
and these things we're working
on for agencies will
ultimately end up there
so that we can use the
reference standards,
use national standards
and publish this stuff
and make it available
for industry to use.
And the process that's
documented there is really good
for how do you develop
information exchanges
and make those useful.
We're kind of at a phase
where we're moving out now
to implement this in software,
so we're going to find
out how this works with
GSA's activities fully.
And this is kind of complemented
by this guide for owners
to help them organize their
information because I think
if you don't ask for it in
the right way you're not going
to get it in the right
way, and as we heard
if you're not validating it
against your requirements you
may not get what you think
you're getting.
So you need to know
how to structure things
so you get what you want.
So there's a lot of good
information out there,
there's a lot of
progress being made,
and it's an interesting
area to work in.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay, great.
Well, that's not too far over.
And we still have 10
minutes for questions.
So any questions?
>> I've got a couple if
nobody else does yet.
Okay, I'll start.
Adoption, so my question is
for both buildingSMART and CAx,
you guys had tons of logos
of who is supporting
the initiatives,
but it's been described
particularly
in the architectural world that
there's a problem with adoption.
So what's the difference
in challenges
between people recognizing,
a broad recognition
that these things need to
happen and investing in them,
but then adopting
them, what's the --
can you talk about
that a little bit?
>> Jeff Ouellette: So from the
buildingSMART perspective the
vendors have worked a lot,
especially in the
last five years,
on implementing these
standards in the software.
Prior to that time we will
admit, I will admit as Chair
of the group, that there
was a lackluster effort
by a lot of the participants.
Fortunately, the demands by
mainly European Governments
and European organizations
have pushed that further,
pushed it to the point where
they say you cannot sell,
or your end users in our
countries will not be able
to provide services to us
unless they use software
that interoperable.
And so that really
lit a fire under a lot
of people's backsides and that
provides a business case then
that says then we
must support this.
The next challenge then, of
course, is to get the end users
to recognize that that
capability is in their software
and that they can use it, and
that we make it easy enough
for them to use, which I think
we do a pretty good job of,
but they need to
understand that it's there.
Yes, Christine, we
could do a lot better.
But think of it as
version 1.0 and, you know,
some of us who know our way
around this application
a little better
than others can make
it do magical things,
but there is the
ability to at least do it
to a rudimentary level, so.
>> Phil Rosche: I wouldn't say
that our experience has been
that much different than yours.
And I think recent
-- is this thing on?
Hello? I think there's been,
you know, it's like 90%
of the development has been done
in the last five or 10 years
and before that it
was everything else.
I think we were lucky in
the mechanical CAD industry
because there's, if you look
at the market there's really
not that many big users.
And I'm just going to pick
a system, I'm not going
to make-up the numbers, but
let's, it's DOS O. You know,
DOS O's 10 biggest customers
probably are 80% of their sales,
it's the Airbus's
and the Boeing's
and the Daimler's of the world.
But what it took for
us was since we are
so concentrated was all those
big people beating the CAD
vendors over the
head with a stick.
We're trying to get computer
aided manufacturing vendors
to implement this capability
now, that's really tough
because you look at the computer
aided manufacturing and it's
like Joe's Machine Shop and he
has one license of Mastercam
and what's Joe going to do, what
does Mastercam care, you know?
So anyway those kind
of our experience.
>> This doesn't really apply
to software preservation.
>> I have a question for Roger.
>> Roger Grant: Okay.
>> Hi, Roger.
>> Roger Grant: Hi, Christine.
>> I'm Christine Falon from
Christie Falon Associates.
Product data, now in
manufacturing if you go
to aerospace stuff is sort of
custom made for a plane, right?
But we use a lot of stuff, what
we call off-the-shelf products
in our buildings, right?
And what I'm running into in
implementations I'm doing is
this kind of great babble
of product data, you know,
what are the properties, what
are the appropriate properties
for a tiller and where
do I get the properties.
And at this point it's an
incredible stupid manual thing.
Is there any movement in
getting manufacturers to agree
on standard property
sets for their products
and delivering them
in a standard format?
>> Roger Grant: Well,
manufacturers have worked
to make their information
available online,
but they haven't structured
it in a common way.
I think that there is movement
in Europe on this subject
because there are EU regulations
that require manufacturers
to report information about
their products in a certain way
and about aspects
of their products.
So that's driving in
Europe a SEN standard,
a common European standard
for how product data
templates should be made.
We're going to adopt
that in buildingSMART
and have it be a
buildingSMART standard.
We're looking at it originating
from IFC because I mean
that an object has
properties and so all
that stuff can be structured.
So I think it's going to
get here, it's starting more
so in Europe, and I think
we'll see that because many
of the manufacturers
are worldwide.
>> Jeff Ouellette: If
you haven't figured
out the common thread or trend
here it's not always starting
in the US.
And the fact of the matter
is if you look, to be honest,
amongst all the software vendors
at least in our industry most
of us make the majority
of our money outside
of the United States,
simple as that.
The United States is a big
market, but the majority
of our money is made
outside the United States.
In 2011 it's a $7 trillion
building industry from design
through production, only $1.7
trillion of it was generated
in the US, $3.5 trillion
was China alone, okay?
So we, again, it's context,
right, we have to look
at the bigger picture of this.
So if significant parts
of our global market are pushing
this forward then we adopt it
and it moves forward
and it becomes a
standard everywhere else,
whether they like it or not.
>> We've got time for one,
maybe two more questions.
>> So this is for Jessica, I
confess a lot of what you talked
about was total new
alien science to me.
I hope I'm not alone in that.
>> Yay.
>> Maybe I can just ask
you to comment on --
because I'm very familiar
with the ISC open data standards
questions, so how does that fit
into the questions
that you're raising?
Why do would you need
to preserve software
if we could just preserve
the data standards?
>> Jessica Meyerson: Sure.
So Tim mentioned this earlier
in the day, so we're kind
of talking about different
sets of stakeholders
and we're talking about
different tax associated
with those different
sets of stakeholders.
So I think future forward
standards approach makes perfect
sense, right?
It's still a complex
digital object,
so ultimately you are going to
have to deal with those layers
of mediation that
will still come
in different versions even
though they can open a file
that includes the same
underlying standards.
So there's that, but the
standards is a future forwards
approach, while at the same
time librarians, archivists,
digital preservationists,
researchers that are looking
at recent history the
last 30, 40, 50 years
or so are still contending
with what we do
with everything that
we already have.
So if we look at collecting
repositories we've invested
since the latter part of since
the '80s I would guess even
earlier maybe, we have things
coming in from the '70s,
we've already been collecting
passively digital objects
and proprietary file formats.
They're embedded
in our collections
and we don't process collections
in archival repositories
at an item level, we bring
them in in an aggregate level
and we describe them
at an aggregate level.
And so what we're finding is
that as researchers come in
and they have these use
cases for access we're faced
with this issue of how do we --
we've already invested
all this time, expertise,
storage resources to go back to
some of Tim's earlier questions
around these digital objects
and they take time to process.
And then we come to the
point of processing them both
for identifying their
historical and cultural value,
what we would call appraisal, as
well as providing access to them
in a reading room
scenario or in sort
of a private network
scenario based
on something like university ID.
So we're sort of looking
at the stuff we already
have primarily right now.
And then what I would say
is the future forward part
of what we do, sort of focused
in cultural memory
broadly defined,
which includes higher
ed, would be scientific
and social scientific
reproducibility.
And so this is also a standards
future forward facing approach
which you have things like
the Software Sustainability
Institute in the UK that's
doing things like helping
to create recommendations
and standards for how
to write better research
software.
But even then, so
you're using some
of the same underlying
libraries,
but you're creating
a unique object.
Another place that
standards sort of plugs
into the Software
Preservation Network of all
of these different organizations
that fit into the network
in different ways, they
have different roles.
So some organizations, in
fact, NIST has a software,
the national software
reference library that's used
as a data corpus just
based on its hash values,
but it is actually
a software library.
And so you have these
known collections
of historical software.
The internet archive,
the national software reference
library, Yale University library
and special collections,
the Computer History Museum.
And so if we think
about the fact
that no one institution
is ever going to be able
to have all the software
they need
to accommodate the use
cases of their end users
for the complex digital
objects that they have
in their collections, we also
are having the same conversation
around standardization.
It's just a different
set of stakeholders.
>> Okay, not to put
you guys on the spot,
but are you all going
to the happy hour?
>> Oh, yes.
>> Okay, so good,
because questions are
up so you've got to ask more.
I'd like to thank
our panel again.
>> Thank you, Kit.
[ Applause ]
>> And now if you'd hang
on for another minute.
Have Tim Walsh come up.
>> Tim Walsh: Okay,
I'll try to keep this
to a reasonable length.
I'd be remiss not to start
with some thank you's.
Personally it's a real honor
to be here giving
these remarks to you.
I think we all owe a giant thank
you to The Library of Congress,
the Architect of the Capitol,
and the National Gallery of Art
for organizing this
really amazing forum.
[ Applause ]
In particular I'd like to thank
Kit, Kate, Leslie and Jamie,
who is still sitting back
there in that solo seat,
for doing so much of the
work for organizing this.
To the Planning Committee,
who put it all together.
You know, these things are
always or almost always sort
of secondary things to all the
important day-to-day challenges
and deadlines and whatever,
so it's a lot of work
and they did a really
good job of it.
And thank you all for being
here, to all the panelists too.
I'm going to try more
or less off the cuff,
although I've been taking
notes frantically all day,
to just kind of parse back
through some of the things
that we have heard and sort of
try to make some connections.
Because I think we heard
a lot of similar comments
and content coming from
different perspectives
that really reflect all
the different stakeholders
that we have, when we're
thinking about the sort
of like long-term
preservation and access
of these very complex,
very software dependent,
although maybe in the
future not quite as much,
which is really encouraging,
kind of digital objects
that we're producing.
So if we start with the
sort of creators, producers,
the architects, the engineers,
the people in aerospace
and automotive, who are actually
creating all these objects
to begin with, I think
we heard a couple things.
One that I think
we could all agree
with in our respective
domains is
that standards are not
so easy to implement.
There's a lot of
work being done.
You know, the buildingSMART
initiative is amazing,
same with the CAx
Implementor Forum.
You see the amount of
resources, both people's time,
people's money, organizational
support by software vendors
and institutions that goes
into making these standards
to begin with, and then they
have to get implemented.
And, like Greg said,
these standards need
to be market based
or the motivation
for using the standards
has to be market based.
This has come up
time and time again,
I mean Roger said
the same thing,
looking at the British
building industry.
There's always going to be
competing higher priorities
than tying everything up
very nicely with a bow
at the end of a project.
So really it has to come back
to things like deliverables,
like externally imposed
requirements.
If we, as Greg said, if the
standards are not only asked
for by clients, by Governments,
by regulatory agencies,
but also tested and verified
then they will happen.
I thought it particularly
interesting comment
from that first session,
too, a couple things.
One, still on standards,
Greg's comment
that we don't have standards
about how you get there,
just what ends up being
delivered is really fascinating
and I think ties into a
lot of the other comments
that we've heard about the need
for say submitting
narratives along with files
or documenting workflows.
This idea that like, especially
in the architectural realm,
especially with smaller
firms every project is going
to have its own workflow and its
own needs and its own software,
unless there's some
reason not to.
But maybe that's okay, it's just
that when it gets ultimately
to other architects,
to architects
at the same firm 20 years
later to deal with the assets,
if it comes to a
place like CCA we have
to know a little bit more.
We can't just be
presented with the files.
I think in our experience at
CCA doing the kind of thing
that Balmori is doing with Yale
is a really great exercise.
We've even sometimes
when we get the files
in basically set-up a
Skype call with the people
who actually created them
and shared our screen
and just walked through
the directories
and like tell me a story about
this, the same way you might do
in history by like
showing someone a photo
to jog their memory.
These kinds of things are
really, really important.
I think we hear some consistent
things about labor and time,
that firms often don't have a
person dedicated to arranging
and scribing the data
or that it's sort
of like a secondary
task at the end.
That it tends to be either
the architects, themselves,
sort of all pulling the
weight or technologists,
who maybe have a
different perspective.
My plug here would be if you
can afford it you should hire
archivists because we
think about this a lot,
but that's not realistic
for everyone.
And like with collecting
institutions no individual firm
or practice is going to solve
these things on their own,
so all these initiatives
that we hear
and they're very collaborative
I think are extremely important
for a firm for moving
us forward.
You know, things like
Lotar is a great example
of basically different, actually
competing commercial entities
recognizing that they
have common problems
and cooperating together
demonstrating the business value
and then actually being
able to implement standards
to drive their cost
down, lower the number
of mistakes being made,
all that sort of thing.
And thinking about the creators.
Also, something that's easy
to forget sometimes I think
for us collecting
institutions who are faced
by how daunting CAT and BIM
and 3 modeling files are
that there's things
besides those
that we need to be collecting.
There's a whole realm of
documentation of knowledge
about corporate culture,
about presices, about events
that predated larger cultural
contexts that shine a light
into why projects
happen as they were,
why designs happened
as they were.
And these things mean that
we're going to be receiving,
thinking about collecting
institutions,
not just an IFC model or not
just CAD files in whatever
of the like 300 possible
formats they're in or whatever,
but also we're going
to be receiving things
like photo documentation
and video and e-mail
and increasingly web
based collaborative
like note platforms
and all kinds of stuff.
And we need to be able
to address all of that,
which means we can't focus all
of our efforts, time and money
on like very selected pies.
I think this also comes back to
collaboration, why this needs
to be a collaborative effort
because there are other people
working in those spaces.
And the Mellon Foundation funded
a really amazing task force
on e-mail archiving, sort of a
state-of-the-art of where we are
with people from a bunch of
major research institutions,
but also others like Microsoft.
And those sorts of things
can really drive us forward.
We, in the ADEAC
realm like don't need
to reinvent the wheel,
we can plug into these
other communities
and like provide our
unique perspective and gain
from other work that's
happening in the field.
And I think there's a little bit
of kind of careful reflection
that we should do
around capturing things
like Matthew called
it capturing culture,
Dennis called it
capturing transactions.
In the end often what
we're interested in,
especially in sort of more
like research institutions,
is not just the end built
product but how we got there,
the theory, the practices.
And for those sorts of things
capturing the cultural elements
that come before are
especially important.
If we sort of move on a little
bit to the second panel,
researchers and scholars,
I loved the quote
from Kurt's colleague, show
me the uses and I'll begin
to understand the value.
Unfortunately, I don't remember
your colleague's name, Kurt,
but that's really great
and I'm really glad
that we had that session today.
Who did that, I think those
of you who are working
with primary, digital primary
source materials are really sort
of on the vanguard.
In some ways there's not a
lot of scholarship out there
that tells us how people
use these materials,
which to me means
I would implore you
to not just share the end
products of your research,
not just like publisher exhibit,
but to share the
process, how you go there.
Like what your research
questions are,
whether you were able to
actually do what you intended
to do or had to change
because of not being able
to find collections or
not being able to do
with collections
what you wanted.
For those of us who
manage these collections
and provide the access to them
these are things that we need
to know in order to
inform our practice
and better serve you in the end.
Another thing that really
struck me is that almost none
of the use cases that
were presented today dealt
with a specific singular
project.
They differed a lot
from how sort
of like traditional
architectural historiography
often gets presented.
Instead it was a lot about
large datasets, comparisons,
design languages, typologies.
I'm wondering if this is because
we now have the technology
to enable these sorts of
researches, if there's something
about this present moment,
or if this interest is going
to continue over time?
I suspect it's the latter,
but the kinds of work
that Andrew is doing
are really innovative,
could not have been predicted
probably 10 or 20 years ago
by collecting institutions
who are ultimately responsible
for a lot of these collections.
And I think that's a thing
that we need to think about,
that maybe we don't need
to over-engineer the ways
that we provide access
or the ways
that we describe
our collections.
Maybe the primary
responsibility for us is
to securely hold these
collections, provide access
as we can, and then
respond to scholarship
and to the actual use,
rather than our sort
of preconceived notions of how
people might want to interact
with this material over time.
Another thing that really
struck me that's a question
that I have no beginning
of an answer
for is I thought there was
a really interesting back
and forth between sort
of Matthew's question
of like can we guess which
software created a file
by the geometry of the
design, versus this idea
of fully interoperable
data that's not tied
to specific software platforms?
I think there's probably
a lot to unpack there,
I don't really know how, I'll
leave that to some of you.
Yes, again, I'd implore you
basically tell us as much
as you can about what you
are doing with this material
and what you want to do.
We will be bound sometimes
by other obligations,
by our donor agreements
for instance.
It's not so easy to
convince donors to give
over 3D high fidelity
representations of buildings
that could be used to
reconstruct it or basically are
like a virtual analog
of a building.
So there are other sort
of factors at play here,
but I think we are, we will
largely be open to reflecting
on our practices and seeing if
we actually are able to break
with some of our older
practices, if we're able
to provide freer
access, if we're able
to better support new
research methodologies.
A couple things for the
collecting institutions
and maybe this is the part where
it might be a bit more of a call
to action for me because this
is my world a little more.
Like I said, let's not start
trying to go from A to Z
and like over-engineering
our access solutions.
From what I hear from Matthew,
from Andrew the collections
that people need to support
scholarship largely are not
in our collecting institutions,
and to me that should
be our first priority,
especially for these sort of
like these first few decades
of digital design where largely
they were incidentally collected
by collecting institutions and
won't be there for very long
for us to collect,
either from people moving
on to different projects,
retiring, the media degrading.
I spend a lot of my days
getting data off of old media,
it's all well past
its reliable lifespan,
there is significant data
corruption in even the stuff
from 10 years ago, 20 years
ago, so that's a real thing.
I think it's really, we
need to think about this,
these sort of new research
methodologies, like I said,
machine learning and
machine vision, AI,
thinking about that our
researchers may not necessarily
want individual drawings,
they might want datasets
and they might be
asking questions
that are not interrogating
a specific architect
or a specific archive but
a specific type of work
that stretches across
archives and practitioners
and whether we can actually
support discoverability
to help people find the
material, like regardless
of its provenance that meets
their research interests,
is an interesting
question to me.
One thing Matthew Allen
said that really struck me,
that a collection of documents
in their original order
provides a lot of clues.
As an archivist that
sort of warmed my heart.
I think it's true.
[laughter] That's been
my experience, too,
that with digital material
especially with all
of the ex-wraps that you can
break if they're not bound in,
all of these things,
often it's better
to leave these collections
as they are and describe them
as best you can and annotate
them with other kinds
of information rather
than going in and trying
to restructure them
and provide some sort
of definitive hierarchical
binding style view
into the material.
And that we can maybe let
people be a little more hands-on
and interactive with digital
archives than we could
with physical, which is
something Matthew brought
up as well.
That, like Euan says, if our
access tools like emulation
as a service allow us
to basically spin-up a new
environment every time that's
identical to the
original one regardless
of what the person came before,
can we be a little freer,
do we actually need to impose
so many restrictions that we had
to largely based around
preservation concerns
that aren't actually
that applicable to a lot
of these new kinds of materials,
I think is another
thing to ponder.
Here's my call to action part.
I think the biggest thing
holding us back as a community
in this is not the difficulty,
not the size of the challenge,
but the size of our capacity.
That in the end of the day
before we can do any of the rest
of the stuff we have to have the
files, we have to collect them,
we have to preserve them.
That means that libraries,
archives
and museums need basic digital
preservation infrastructure,
which is easier than
it used to be.
There's a lot of really maturing
software out there, standards,
professional communities.
But at the end of
the day regardless
of how you implement digital
preservation it does mean
that you are going to have to
dedicate staffing and funding
to it, which is as far
as I can see maybe one
of the biggest obstacles
to really moving
forward as a community.
And we've been talking
about a lot of these issues
for 20 years now and I think
we have a pretty good idea
of what we need to
do at this point,
we just need more
resources behind it.
That's not all our fault,
though, because most
of us don't have more
resources than we used
to have even though we
have all these new types
of assets to handle.
So I think funding institutions,
too, should take this
into consideration, but
ultimately it's probably going
to require a lot of critical
evaluation of our services,
where we spend our money.
Maybe not everyone
needs to do it
and probably not everyone needs
to do it and not everyone needs
to collect at a large
scale, but if you want
to it requires funding
and staffing ultimately.
I think that said, we
don't have to start
with the complete solution for
these things right off the bat.
Things like the NDSA levels
of digital preservation
are there to guide us.
It's best to start at a level
where you know what you have,
you know that you have backups,
you know that you can restore
from those backups, and
then iterate up from there.
There's a lot of education
and training out there.
I think one of the things
that didn't really get
addressed today all that much,
except maybe obliquely through
some questions, is training
and staffing around working with
these materials and archives,
that suddenly we're expected
to have these competencies,
that we understand archival,
we have archival expertise,
we understand the sort
of architecture, design,
engineering worlds,
we understand how
to operate this CAD software
at least well enough to open
up the files and look
around and say what they are
and to describe them
to other people
who probably have
more expertise than us
in a way that's not invalid.
Somehow we have to develop
a whole community of people
like this and I think
we're getting there,
but we can use some
critical self-reflection
about how we set-up, how we
have training for current staff,
how we encourage
a new generation
of people to come into this.
Things like the NDSR residency
program are fantastic,
maybe we should think
about an NDSR architecture.
I think there's a lot of
things that we could do
as a community in there.
Just like in aerospace
and in the building community
we need to work together.
We heard over and over and
over again today no one person
or institution will solve
everything, we all are coming
at this with different
expertise, different resources,
different use cases, and the
more we work together the more
we're going to work through
a lot of these issues.
And in terms of practice,
like I said earlier,
we can't really focus only
on CAD and BIM and models,
we have to take a
larger picture approach.
We have to think about how we
document culture and workflow
and process and context
so that we don't just end
up with some models that
are very extremely preserved
in like perfect interoperable
file formats,
but with no real
context for them.
I think the last thing I'd say
for the collecting institutions,
for my fellow people from
collecting institutions
in the room, is it's
on us to demonstrate
that our business case
exists and is viable.
And we heard this
from the other types
of stakeholders again today,
over and over and over,
if you want people to
care about your problem,
if you want to move forward
you have to demonstrate
that it matters, why it matters
and that there's a way forward.
And that's on us collectively.
For the representatives of
software companies in the room
or that might be watching
this at YouTube in the future,
I think a few considerations.
From architectural
and engineering firms,
to facility managers, to
librarians and archivists,
to Governments, we've heard
from a lot of people today
that they are interested
in retaining access
to files created in older
versions of your software.
And maintaining compatibility
with old file formats
and versions and ensuring that
your software can write files
in preservation friendly openly
documented file formats have a
real big role to impacts.
There's been a lot of movement
on that front around BIM
and IFC especially, which is
fantastic, but it's a thing
that we can forget over time.
And we live in a world now
where even a W creative
cloud can't open the earliest
Photoshop files and
Microsoft Word can't open
up early Word files and those
are much simpler assets.
So we have to think about
these things in terms
of business value
clearly, but also in terms
of their cultural
value and significance.
As Euan demonstrated, there's
also quite a lot of us out there
who are interested in running
older versions of the software
in like virtual machines
and emulators,
whether it's the
software vendors,
whether it's software developers
who just think on their own.
This is a really
interesting topic,
whether it's institutions
thinking about applying
for grants, we could use a
whole lot more development
around these kinds of tools.
What Euan has been able to do
and Klaus has been able to do
and other people have
been able to do, you know,
Rhizome for instance
applying this
in the art world is amazing, but
it will only continue forward
with kind of like funding and
support and given the promise,
that's something we
should all think about.
And, finally I think as a member
of the Software Preservation
Network myself,
I love that Jessica stressed
this, we need to acknowledge
that software is infrastructure,
that it's a tool,
that it's a way of
interacting with data,
but also that it's our
cultural heritage and we need
to think about that somehow.
It's tough because there's
always business interests
on the line and that's
completely understandable,
but increasingly as the products
of our creative activities,
commercial activities are
increasingly software dependent,
bound now more and more online
which only increases
these dependencies,
I do think that there's a
valid argument to be made
that there's a sort of
cultural element to this,
a cultural obligation to this.
I'm not the only one, you know,
UNESCO has the Persist Project
that's recognizing the same
exact thing on an
international level.
For the standards
organizations in the room,
you all are awesome,
keep doing that work.
[laughter] Pushing for open
and documented standards.
I found it very interesting
that the compatibility
and adoption is increasingly
there,
also that it's increasingly
there
because Governmetns largely
in Europe are increasingly
requiring it,
which tells us a lot.
For the clients and
Government agencies in the room,
how we get things done and how
we ease our collective problems,
you know, that the
power of regulation
and deliverables
requirements is probably one
of the biggest powers
in the space
for making things happen came
up over and over and over.
I'm also really glad
that we ended
on two buildingSMART
presentations
because I think it
outlines the kind
of bright future
that's ahead of us.
That, like Jessica said, we're
going to have to continue
to deal with the old stuff and
that will require all kinds
of creative solutions, it will
inevitably result in some loss,
that's okay, that's the way
the world has always worked.
But for the path ahead we
can at least try to lay
down these standards,
encourage their adoption
as much as possible.
Again, for the collecting
institutions in the room,
I think a lot of us archivists
and librarians have skills
in terms of knowledge and
information organization
and long-term preservation
that we're keeping
within our professional
confines.
It might behoove us to
think in a slightly more
like post-custodial model,
like go to conferences
that aren't library conferences,
go to meetings of architects
and designers and
engineers and talk
about why we organize
information the way that we do
and try to make that
a back and forth.
In general I think clearly
collaborative discussions
and efforts are going to
be the key in all of this.
And I thought I would, you know,
we all benefit from standards,
we all benefit from
openly documented formats,
good documentation,
from the firms themselves
who want to go back and look
at materials, to scholars,
to collecting institutions,
it's really everyone.
And I thought I would leave this
by just reiterating
Roger's comment,
we have to invest upfront
to save in the end,
which I think ultimately
underscores a lot
of what happened here today.
A lot of that investment
is happening already.
It's clear, look at how
many people are in this room
that are doing amazing
work on this problem
from so many different angles,
coming from so many different
stakeholder communities.
It's fantastic, but it's up to
us to continue the good fight.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Stacy: So thanks,
Tim, that was great.
It was a wonderful
wrap-up of the day
and I really enjoyed
your call to action,
so I think it gives us
a place to move forward.
I'd like to give just one
more round of applause to all
of our speakers today.
It's been a long day, but I
think it's been a great day.
[ Applause ]
It's hard to absorb all of
this stuff when you're sitting
in the audience on the
first go, so a reminder
that this is being
taped for YouTube
and we will have a report about
the themes of the day coming
out in probably early 2018 and
we'll distribute those widely.
A quick announcement, on
behalf of Nancy for IPRES 2018,
is going to be in Boston.
And correct me if
I get this wrong,
September 24th through
27th, 2018.
Okay, great, so be
on the lookout
for calls for papers for that.
Those of you who
are participating
in our workshop tomorrow
please go to the cafeteria
and we'll do a little powwow.
The rest of you should
go to Bull Feathers
and order me a Chardonnet, okay?
[laughter] Okay, so
thanks so much for coming
and it's been a great
experience,
and we hope you have
enjoyed it as well.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.